our first bill
uh i want to remind folks on the
education committee the house education
committee that there are bills being
heard in senate education as well
concurrently
tomorrow there will be some bills coming
up uh bills coming up in senate ed
tomorrow are 16 24
1671 16 27 and 11 35.
so look at the senate calendar don't say
well we're all done and finished here we
may be finished at this level until we
get to the next step but uh
be watching that senate calendar in
addition i provided everybody a copy of
a report which i
asked the department to provide me it's
just kind of a summary of where we are
with the uh cares act and all the esser
ones to cetera and the uh american
rescue plan that this reports effective
march 31
2022 you didn't get yours did you mark
we can pass one around here
there's one for representative hall
so uh on that you can look at and see
what monies have been allocated to those
school districts and to what degree it's
been spent already
uh information that we want to stay on
top of
so today we have uh five bills and the
first bill was supposed to start right
at nine o'clock that's close enough for
house time
um
we'll start ahead here and we uh
recognize
representative um
not senator senator ward
if i can get the right day here
for sb 238 relative to special education
services in charter public schools
welcome senator ward
thank you
mr chair and
welcome or
good morning to all the committee
members
this is senate bill 238
i move senate bill 238 ought to pass
with amendment
this bill would require charters public
schools to enter into a memorandum of
understanding with the resident school
district concerning special education
service
for a
chartered public school student with
disabilities mousse are guiding
documents frequently used in local
government that clarify the roles and
responsibilities of each individual in
an mou
these mousse would not interfere or
undermine any standing contracts already
in effect in resident districts
a committee amendment was adopted to
require a chartered public school and
resident district to review the mou at
least two weeks prior to the start start
of the school year
the education committee asked for your
support on the motion of ought to pass
with amendment on senate bill 238 thank
you mr chair thank you senator are there
any questions of senator ward
from the committee
represent cordelia
thank you mr chair uh thank you senator
ward for
bringing this to us
would there be uh one
blanket mou between the charter school
and the district or would there be a an
mou for each uh child with a disability
in the charter school
very good question i would think that it
has to do with each individual because
each individual child will have
different
needs but it needs to be addressed and
shared between the dissenting district
school and the accepting
charter public charter school
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions of senator ward yes
represent woodcock
thank you good morning
um i'm looking at the
the last part lines 50 16 and 17.
i'm particularly concerned with the
notification on 16 and
if a youngster with disabilities uh to
receive services what happens if the
two-week deadline can't be met at that
point right before school opens
uh you're looking at the bill amended by
the senate i'm looking at the back of
the bill that was distributed this
morning
i haven't seen is this
the line it talks about the two week the
two week uh period prior to start of
school
if a youngster is if that mou or the
review doesn't happen that two weeks
what happens
could you state that again
yes i'll try to reframe it here okay
the
lines 16 and 17 are talking about a
two-week review um
for youngsters with special education
plans or in a shot of public school
and it's in the last two weeks two weeks
before school starts and my question is
what happens if that doesn't occur
during that time frame
well i think that is the reason we have
this bill is because that has occurred
so the receiving charter
ends up with a child with disabilities
and they have really not very little
they have earlier information on what to
do and i think this bill will put it in
writing that they have to meet they have
to have an mou between the sending
school district and receiving charter
school as so
the best plan for this particular child
so it has to take place
okay
thank you
senator ward i i have one question here
um where
if the mou
is done prior to
that meeting
or even after it
um the
language and lines 9 through
11 speak to the what the mou may contain
it may contain services that will be
provide provided
where the server school district will
provide the services directly and if
they're going to do it through a
contracted service
if
those are usually decisions which are
made
during the iep process
and written into the iep
uh so i would assume then the mou and
and correct me if i'm wrong please the
mou is is is
done after the iep or you see i'm a
little confused whether it's done prior
to or or pri afterwards if it's
afterwards then this is stuff's already
in the iep
is so is the mou primarily then
established for the purpose of
notification that we will be having a
meeting and the meeting will be
conducted where my understanding is that
we're talking about a child who has
spent time in the public school system
and is now moving to a public charter
school so he he or she has already had a
plan and that plan needs to be reviewed
and discussed with the accepting charter
school
so
as far as i'm concerned you can discuss
this more than two weeks before if you
know that the child is moving over
then
anytime you can sit down and talk about
it the better it is
so a follow-up then it's it's my concern
though that
the
these types of things are decided at the
iep meeting by all those that are
required by law to be there
um
then if it's done prior to the
iep are we then conducting another iep
prior to the iep
uh i i i can't answer that
i don't know okay thank you
rep san luna
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much senator ward for uh for
being with us this morning um i see um
in the um in the the bill docket for uh
for 238 that there were three amendments
um to it um leading up to the uh the
the bill is amended by the senate and i
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about the um the cooperation or
collaboration collaboration with um with
school administrators and uh special ed
uh special education administrators
in the development of uh the amendments
that lead the bill that we're seeing
today
there was quite a discussion
between the needs of the charter schools
who felt that they were never really
told ahead of time and not enough time
for them to plan what kinds of services
that the child would need to have that's
why we have at least two weeks
beforehand there certainly was input
from the school administrators and from
special education teachers and at one
point i know that senator khan had
talked to the
special education teachers and they
essentially said yeah two weeks is okay
but it would be better to have this
conference this mou before even at 30
days before the school starts
so there were a lot of people involved
in the and the department of education
as well
thank you
further questions
representative tanner
thank you for taking my question thank
you senator ward um when when is a
school actually
notified that a student has gone to a
charter school
um
so they're they're a member of the
of the public school and then they
decide sometime to to enter charter
school and go through that acceptance
process
when
do they know
like a month ahead of time before or do
some of them
uh find out like the day of the first
day of class
so i'm just wondering how this two-week
period fits with that
i am assuming based on my understanding
of these things that the charter schools
will have
opened you know you can apply to the
charter school and if there is a space
and you qualify for that space then they
can start then they can initiate the mou
then they know that the child is coming
over
i doubt that it happens the day before
unless men i've seen
cases where some this
severely disabled child comes into the
public school system and they had not
planned for it and all of a sudden the
second semester here you have an
additional child which raises a lot of
concerns as far as how you pay for it
and how how you take care of it so
my understanding is that the receiving
charter school will know beforehand if
the child comes from the public school
system
further questions yes represent cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question
so then it would be up to the charter
school to notify the public school that
a student has registered and and to get
this process going
that is the way it has been and i think
the charter school would like to know
from the sending school that this child
is leaving and coming to the charter
school
and the charter school can then talk to
them and set up a time and discuss you
know a mutually acceptable time for them
to sit down and discuss this child's
needs
further questions yes yes but i'm
assuming that the charter school knows
before the public school does that the
child is leaving the public school and
going to the charter school because
they've been accepted and then the
charter school will notify the public
school
that that they need to set up this
meeting to do this
i don't know how that works i don't know
if the public school
if some if a parent comes and tells it
excuse me
comes and tells the public school we're
taking our child out
and we're going to transfer him or her
to this other school
i would think that
i don't think a child shows up in the
charter school
without having notified the public
school because of the
education money that is involved
somebody needs to know pretty early on
where this child is going to be the next
full school year
further questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you have a good day
i will
john are you here for it okay
next card is jane bergeron
new hampshire association special ed
administrators
welcome
thank you very much good morning
for the record my name is jane bergeron
bull you and i'm the executive director
of the new hampshire association of
special ed administrators here
representing over 280 leaders in the
field of special education
my testimony is going around i will keep
it short
our association does see the value of an
mou but the bill as written
raises a lot of questions and
needs quite a bit more clarity the first
thing
is around some of the conversation that
just happened in regards to an mou being
a one-on-one agreement versus an
agreement between the district and the
charter school in regards to the
provision of special education
we were under the impression that this
was an mou that would be a agreement
between
the two entities now it seems as though
we're talking one-on-one which doesn't
seem relevant when kids already have an
iep which
covers the the specifics of the the
child
also um in looking at the bill there was
a you know a lot of questions around
this two week uh prior to school
starting
kids enter into charter schools at all
time of the year so a bill that states
uh two weeks prior to the start of the
school year may not be relevant for
many of the the children who are
enrolling
um also we'd like to say that you know
in terms of the leas we fully understand
our responsibility in terms of the
provision of special education services
and this bill
is requiring an mou which we wouldn't
oppose but there really isn't any
evidence that there's been a pattern of
non-compliance in terms of our school
districts not adhering to their
requirements and their obligation for
the provision of special education
services to students with disabilities
um and so for this reason uh we wouldn't
really see that this is necessary and
would open it up to any of you for uh
questions that you might have for me
thank you very much are there questions
of the special ed administrators
yes representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here
if
a child
is in a public school and then enrolls
in a charter school there would be an
existing iep
but
when they go to the charter school one
of the main issues we've heard from
parents
is
where the services are provided now that
wouldn't necessarily be in the um
iep unless there's a new iep
at the beginning of the school year so
wouldn't that would be one of the main
things that would be covered in the mou
as to where the services are to be
provided because they're now in a
charter school but the resident district
is responsible for the services
thank you for the question that
certainly would be a good example of
what could be contained in a memorandum
of understanding we wouldn't be opposed
to that i mean that's something that we
talk about with the charter schools and
the parents
and that it isn't a part of the iep
representative woodcock
thank you chamberlain good morning how
are you doing um this is a quick
question i i
thank you for speaking because i was i
was confused as i was reading the mou
and i asked my associate here three
times and she made it more confusing
so
i appreciate you clarifying that i
couldn't see one on one or one on i
didn't understand the whole the concept
that um i want to refer back to um
representative cordelli's question
though uh
when where the servers are going to be
provided this says that the doe will
provide a guide create a guide document
but i thought the services provided
would be if it's going to be one
standard template that would be wouldn't
be there because every district is going
to be different so i'm not sure how that
would work but
in the iep
am i wrong that the or do i understand
correctly that when the services when
you negotiate the service with the
parent and the youngsters
in the schools this service are going to
be provided here because that's the only
place we have it the server's going to
be provided there and that's all
delineating the iep
in terms of the location yes it's the
actual service itself so if you know
they need orton gillingham reading and
the charter school can't provide that
they decide if the provider is going to
go to the school right or if the child
is going to go back to the public school
that's all part of that conversation yes
that's that's agreed upon and the iap
and the parents sign off yeah i don't
understand what the mou would do to that
you know if from my lens um you know an
example would be in an mou knowing the
schedule when the service providers are
going to show up so it's not you know
random and the charter school doesn't
get surprise
um or or if they're going to leave to go
to the public school that that's agreed
upon and it's not disruptive to the
child that's a reasonable
agreement to have all right thank you
thank you chairman thank you um i have a
question for you um in the past we've
heard testimony from various folks that
it's taking quite a while before the
service is delivered to this child at
the charter school for example a new
child that moves in that has multiple
handicaps came in from another state
it's not that charter school
so my concerns go back still to is this
an agreement but
on a one-on-one regarding each child or
is it an agreement between
one organization to another organization
generally how we're going to conduct
our relationship here
and it goes into the question regarding
contracted services if it's a one-on-one
i think it's virtually impossible
to
identify and i know it says may contain
it's not saying shall contain
but if you're a small district that
doesn't have a person person's going to
deal with an orthopedic handicap or a
traumatic brain injury or a multiple
handicap that this child has
then you're going to have to do it
probably through a contracted service
but you don't know that until you're in
the iep meeting and you're dealing with
it seeing you've never seen that iep
before it came in from another state
so how would we respond and how would we
work this into the
into a
a one-on-one between
no
organization and organization at the
beginning year i think that's virtually
impossible to do
thank you for the question and you bring
up an important fact that you know we're
so short staffed in the state of new
hampshire when it comes to special
education service providers whether it
be in our public schools or charter
schools so
in some situations yes it's very
difficult to get those services started
on time i think folks do a really good
job of documenting every effort to get
those
and to your point about duplication
one-on-one agreements
we're confused about that too
in terms of what that would look like
when you already have an iep which is
basically the legal
document i'm not sure what a one-on-one
memorandum of understanding would
contain we've had some
really
strong conversations with the department
um
very productive conversations about what
might be in an mou
and i think becky ferdet could probably
expand on that we've tossed around some
reasonable ideas i'm not quite sure that
the charter school association is on
board with this and she can probably
give you more information about that
but truly an mou is an agreement between
all of the organizations involved and
it's collaborative in nature
and i'm not sure that the charter
schools even want this kind of mou
agreement
thank you for the further questions
representatives
i have two questions if that's okay one
is when are ieps usually done
um you know every district has a
different cycle some do them
um by birth date some do them you know
by the end of the school year so it's
truly left up to the school district and
parent they have to be done every year
but some districts schedule them
throughout the school year some wait and
do them all towards the end of the
school year so it varies
so but there normally would be
prior to the following year is that
am i understanding you right
like if it's here yeah but i mean like
if it's done if most of them do it
towards the end of the year
that would
then the school the next year would know
what was expected at the beginning of
the year is that my in my understanding
right what the charter school would
expect no no no if you don't know let's
say you don't know the kids going into
the charter school yet you're in the
public school
and you do the iep at the regular iep
time
and then the parent once decides that
the next year they're going to go
to the charter school with the iep
normally have already been done
again it's it's by the district we have
a lot of school districts who are not
doing their meetings at the end of the
year just simply because there's a
backload and service providers are taken
away from kids so they're trying really
hard to stagger them throughout the
school year okay
but so then that's well that was the uh
i was first or the second question that
was the first question i was trying to
make sure i understood that that's the
second one and the second one is
could the mou be done at
i mean if you know the kid is going to
the charter school or is in the charter
school could the mou and the ib iep be
done at the same meeting
that's my second question
um
again i'm not sure what a one-on-one mou
would contain so it's hard to answer
that question
okay thank you you're welcome are there
further questions represented moffatt
thank you mr chair and thank you ms
bergeron for being here um in your
testimony which i'm reading you said
that your organization would welcome the
opportunity to collaborate with doe and
the public charter schools to work on
the template
in the mou expectations so my question
is
would you
do you see an opportunity in the short
term given we have a timeline to perhaps
work up an amendment or some language
that one of us could uh submit so that
we could discuss an amendment um
that would be to your liking we could
certainly go back to our association
members and talk with the department
about that um but right now there's
so many questions for us that are you
know not clear um but we could certainly
go back and talk with our members
thank you thank you further further
questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you um we do have uh becky here as a
technical support however jerry fruit do
you want to prior to from the school
administrators association then we can
have becky come up from the department
if there's tech questions
sure mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity my name is jerry fru
associate executive director with the
school administrators association nice
to see you all again i won't take a lot
of time i had not prep i had not
prepared uh to speak at all on this this
morning because
until it was presented
i thought i understood what was being
presented but then there's confusion
around
we view the mou as an organizational
document and in terms of how
organizations are going to interact to
provide services to kids we
never saw the mou as a one to one
document to begin with we see that as
the iep and within the iep you identify
services that need to be be provided but
then the overarching umbrella of the mou
would address how those services would
be provided and so
i don't have anything to hand out
because we have we are concerned if the
mou was indeed a one-on-one document
and frankly i'm i'm a bit surprised that
the charter school folks on here i would
envision this to be a pretty onerous
responsibility on the positive charter
schools and i think about
one where our grandchildren went i i
believe that they dealt with 17
different communities and i can't
imagine that they have the bandwidth to
deal with perhaps you know uh 20 or 30
of their students in over 17 different
communities dealing with a one-on-one
mou i
i would i would just my heart would
bleed for what they have to go through
so i think the organizational piece of
the mou is the important part and and um
that's all
that i'll say thank you very much are
there questions of these yes represent
luno
sure thanks very much mr chair and
thanks very much um um jerry for for
being with us this morning um
yeah i'm
i
i don't um see where the one-on-one uh
part is in here but but let's just just
for the sake of the question
uh assume that that we're talking about
an mou that's between
a uh school district and a truck and a
chartered a charter school
not a not on a per student basis but
just an agreement um how would how would
this
um bill
do anything beyond what is currently in
existing law and referenced in the bill
at 194 b colon 11 roman 3 c
which says and the chartered public
schools shall cooperate with the child's
resident district in the provision of
the ch of the child special education
and related services thank you for that
question
representative
i do think there
and we we see value in the mou piece
itself because it does it would offer
the opportunity to clearly explain uh
from the get-go uh who's responsible for
what and and it would allow i believe
the opportunity to address some of the
staffing issues in a document where
staffing shortages are real and they're
real in our schools and when a special
education teacher leaves partway through
the year and that has happened on on a
number of occasions not only does that
leave the
local
resident district in the lurch but it
also leaves the charter school services
in the lurch and so those are those are
real things that are going to happen and
perhaps could be addressed in an mou
with a mutual understanding and
agreement that if we have a vacancy xyz
is going to be the process so that so
that the adversarial relationship you
know between you know you have the
charter school folks saying we need the
services for the kids and then you have
the
the resident district saying yes but we
don't have the staff we don't we've just
lost services to our kids as well
at the end of the day they are all our
kids whether they're charter school or
whether they're resident schools and
it's it's imp the imperative is to
provide the services and the mou is the
opportunity to address that
those issues that may come up and say
okay this is how we're gonna work this
out as opposed to having hard feelings
and accusations that well you're not you
know doing xyz well
so i think the mou is an opportunity but
i it's just not ready for prime time as
as
we've heard say in this
party
representative uh waltz
uh what i have is actually more of a
comment than a question and i think the
pro one of the confusion here
comes from the drafting and the bill and
i want to point out that on line three
it refers to a student
on line seven it refers to students
plural to students and then down on line
16 it says a student again so the bill
is inconsistent whether we're talking
about an individual agreement or
agreement overriding overarching
agreement for all students and i just
wanted to point that out that i think
that may be where some of the confusion
is coming from
thank you representative woodcock thank
you chairman good morning i just want to
follow up on your your uh inference
about a charter school having multiple
school districts uh i think you use the
term 17
coming to one charter school which could
clearly happen
would it be your understanding in this
bill does that mean there would be 17
different mous
if there were 17 districts yes so they
could be particularly completely
different and if there were one-on-one
students in each of the 17 districts
there could be
70 mlus okay yeah thank you thank you
uh jerry uh on line six through
or excuse me five through nine there is
a sentence
which i think that sentence alone deals
with the organizational to
organizational units
talking about cooperating in conjunction
with the statute
and the types of services for students
if this
legislation were boiled down to this
particular area would your organization
be in support
we support the idea of having the
agreements and and see where that could
be valuable but we need it needs to be
very clear yeah thank you
further questions from the committee
yes represent luna thank you very much
and um and i i think uh chair ladd's uh
question there i think is was was very
helpful as well as your answer jerry
would um would a would it would a
an mou that was really specific to be
between a district and a charter
not on a student-specific basis um
and you suggested that it it could could
address
what would happen if staffing um
uh uh changes were made or or or have
happened would it also possibly include
reimbursement agreement for
reimbursement rates and things like that
absolutely i think that's the
that's the opportunity that the mou
would provide okay and and it's not not
on a student-specific basis but on a on
a more of a a school-to-school basis
represent like us
we we do have becky coming up also okay
so this
we can take input from either one or
both of them
i was in re-reading it
based on the things that you were saying
and everybody was saying
it seems to me that the mou is between
the school district
and the charter school
but that two weeks prior to the charter
school say you have a kid with an iep
that has something that you didn't
consider it says it shall be reviewed
make sure that everybody is covered so
so it seems like it's a little of each
that when you have a particular kid
you're gonna just review the moe and
make sure this kid's covered by the
agreement in case there was something
you didn't think of that's
i guess my reading of it
what do you i just wondered if you've
gone through this what do you think
thank you for the question
representative i
i'm not sure and i i know
that legislative intent is a big deal
and given the the way this unraveled
this morning a little bit i'm not quite
certain what the legislative intent is
and i think that needs to be clarified
before this goes any further that's the
perfect question for somebody other than
me
thank you thank you very much uh i think
what we're going to do now is go to
becky from the department quickly and
see if there's any technical questions
thank you very much mr freud
good morning good morning it's monday
it's monday
i think that uh for the record my name
is rebecca fred i'm the state director
of special education um
i think that
um our understanding of this this
document was that the mou would be a um
one document for each school district
that the chartered school works with i
think that our when we spoke with both
the new hampshire association of special
education directors and chartered school
organization we had discussed how we
really needed a clarification of
what that that cooperation between the
two entities would look like a ch an iep
is going to tell you the frequency
duration and setting of a service that
is provided but the setting is going to
be a regular education setting a special
education setting so while you may
discuss in a meeting
that
orton gillingham is going to be provided
back at the regular school that isn't
always what the discussion is in the iep
team meeting so this would be where
you're clarifying that
i have we have six students that need
orton gillingham instruction it's going
to be easier for us to send that
instructor to the charter school to
provide services then take all of those
students back here so it's it wasn't
intended to to be a kind of one-on-one
um
document it was intended to say
overarching if we look at our six
students that come to your school how
are we going to work together to get
these services in place am i going to
contract with you am i going to contract
with somebody else am i going to send my
own person from my own district to come
do these services so it was really those
logistics because that was what we had
heard was the concern there wasn't the
concern with the iep or what the
services were stated in the iep there
was the concern of how those logistics
were kind of figured out and and
determined between the school district
and the chartered organization because
they we found many times there was a
different interpretation of what had
been discussed and so this was kind of
putting it into a document and saying
clearly this is what your responsibility
is this is what your responsibility is
so that there was no misunderstanding
three six months down the road when one
entity received a bill from the other
one or one entity asked for payment for
something else it was to very clearly
state this is what you have said you're
going to do this is what you have said
you're going to do
thank you are there questions
representative porter
thank you mr chair
i don't know if this is
the other right person to ask this but
my mind has been trying to
get around the fact that somebody a
charter school might have kids from 17
different districts and so 17 different
districts will be providing
special education services to the
children at the charter school
in my experience in the classroom
of the regular public school when there
were a group of children who had the
same sort of needs the the group would
meet as
because of staffing and needing to be
efficient so all five kids from five
different classrooms would all go to the
special ed room and get the service that
they need
in the charter school with 17 different
districts
if there are 17 kids all with the same
special ed need do they all get serviced
by their individual district then or
that's what that mou would clarify so if
they if you with that scenario if you
had 17 students who needed orton
gillingham instruction i'm just going to
keep building off of jane's conversation
and they needed orton gillingham
instruction the charter school could say
i have two from you and two from you and
two from you we're willing to you know
if you can all contribute we're willing
to hire a teacher to teach those 17
students so that i'm not making i'm not
having you send somebody and i'm having
you pay for something and i'm having you
take the kids back to your school we're
trying to make that agreement so that
it's easier to say
you know you all need this i'll agree
with you to do this and there may be
some nuances though if you have a
student who has a one-on-one in one
district but maybe not in another
district so it's clarifying those but it
would give them the opportunity to also
say we can do this because we have all
of these students that need that same
service
thank you
representative ellison
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question
building on the examples we're using
uh
with 17 school districts sending
students to a chiro school
even if it's a an agreement between the
district and the charter school we're
talking about 17 separate agreements is
that correct yes but it wouldn't be a it
would be less than if you took all 30
kids that came from those 17 schools and
wrote 30 individual
mouss so that was why we did that's
another thing is it's only going to be
for the district they already have to
cooperate with that district and they're
already making these agreements so it's
just putting it into a
document follow-up uh quick follow-up so
uh actually the number of mouss that
would be in place
is determined by the number of school
districts sending students to that
charter school yes they should be
getting could be getting
students from 25 districts there had to
be 25 mous at that point is that the
highest i've heard is is 14 or 17 so but
yes it could thank you jeff santana
thank you and thank you for taking my
question my question is about the guide
that the doe is
supposed to develop and provide
um
could you tell me
kind of explain to me a little bit about
how that
that guide is going to be developed and
what exactly might be in that is is it
kind of open-ended questions or is it uh
prescriptive
so um
we would want to collaborate with both
the charter schools and most likely the
association of special ed directors to
ensure that we're getting some clear
questions in there but it really would
state where services are going to be
provided for the students so is it going
to be that
the students are at the charter school
or that the students are going back to
the resident district um who's paying
for portions of those if you agree that
the child is going to receive the
services there are you then contracting
with that chartered school to pay them a
portion of that um
it so really just clarify as it those
those details of how you're cooperating
yes we're going to send the students
there yes we're going to pay you for
this
um or
any of those details that that may not
be worked out in your iep team meeting
yes
thank you um and how is that mediated uh
if there's like strong disagreement
which we've heard in the past between
the charter school and the sending
district
uh
that's a good question
there is no um there's no mechanism for
a mediation of that they
this the chart the um
the district is responsible for those
services so they need to be able to
determine how they're going to provide
those services
um
they could always ask for our support
but it's not something that we would i
mean there ultimately they have to
provide the services this is just how
are you going to provide them
thank you further questions from the
committee
nancy thank you very much
i do not have any other pink cards on
this oh
from the school boards association
i apologize i was not going to speak on
this but there's a few things i'd like
to
just offer the committee for the record
becky wilson from new hampshire school
boards association
i would agree with the previous speakers
that when this bill was originally
discussed in senate education
i think the majority of people felt that
mou was really a district and charter
school level
document
different districts have different
resources different charter schools have
different resources in our minds the mou
is really
about global decision making in terms of
who is responsible for what decisions
between the charter school and the local
district from a more of a school board
perspective and more of a management
things like who's hiring the staff who's
responsible for hiring certain staff
who's responsible for supervising that
staff member if they are a district
employee versus a charter school
employee
who's setting the rate i think that was
brought up previously
what's the collaboration between the
public charter school and the local
district in terms of supervision of the
staff evaluation
and to just try to clarify and limit
confusion between charter schools and
local districts about decision making
authority
in our minds the iep team is the one
that is making the decisions for student
level
decision making where services are going
to be provided what are the services
what needs to be translated from when
the student was in the local public
school to the charter school how might
things look different
those are all iep team decisions and the
iep team is required to meet when the
student enrolls
at the public charter school
there was also some discussion
previously about
you may have students at public charter
schools who do not require special ed
services so not every school district is
going to automatically have an mou with
every public charter school you're only
going to enter into this
once you know that you have a student
who has enrolled in the public charter
school
that may not be prior to the start of
the school year while that's ideal i
think for most people that's not always
the case there are students that
move during the school year or enroll
over time
and there was quite a bit of discussion
about this two weeks prior to the school
year
requirement that uh if it's going to be
between
the
district staff for example the special
education director or the superintendent
and the administrator at the local
public charter school
those people are available over the
summer but if there's some expectation
that there's other people involved not
all of those people are available prior
to the school year starting
and not all of those decisions um you
know at the student level necessarily
are going to be
made prior to the start of the school
year so i just wanted to clarify that
from from the school board's perspective
we're seeing this as a
very similar to other mousse that you
might have for example with the police
department if you have a school resource
officer about who's doing what uh who's
responsible for what decisions
who makes the final call etc so i'm
happy to take any questions thank you
very much are there any questions
representative moffitt
thank you mr thank you miss whitley for
being here and this question perhaps may
have been better addressed to the
previous speaker but let me ask you
uh schools especially charter schools
have finite capacities
so my question has to do with
the discretion that charter schools have
in terms of accepting
numbers or certain
students um can
can
public charter schools uh opt to just
not uh accept
certain special needs students or can
you speak to that thank you for the
question um you certainly could ask out
of the department as well but they are
public schools they are required to
look at all students who want to enroll
there and the iep team is required to
meet once the student enrolls there to
talk about how what accommodations and
modifications the student would need to
be able to participate
thank you you're welcome representative
mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question over there ms wilson
my question is about whether or not in
your review of mousse because i would
imagine your agency sees a fair number
of them
are there ever provisions in the mou to
evaluate the effectiveness of the mou
thank you for the question there
typically are timelines built in to
review the mou
and to ensure that it's you know meeting
the needs of both parties i think that
is where we feel that the model from the
department would be helpful i think both
for local charter schools who are going
to have a number of districts and if
this were to pass in terms of trying to
negotiate these multiple mous
but again to your to your point i think
to representative moffett's point
different districts and different
charter schools have different resources
so what the specifics of what might need
to be contained in each mlu might be a
little bit different so it would be
important to review those on a regular
basis i think once you have a student
enrolled in the public charter school
who requires special education services
and you have an mou
it would make sense that you would
review it on a regular basis
but again that doesn't
change the fact that if you were to have
one student with special education needs
who enrolls in the local public charter
school and you develop an mou you're
reviewing that child's iep as an iep
team if another student from your
district enrolls in that same charter
school
you're not necessarily doing a new mou
you already have that but you are having
another iep team meeting for that
particular student to talk about that
particular student's needs and how those
are going to be met in the public
charter school
thank you are there any further
questions of becky
thank you very much
and with that i have no further cards
for this bill so we will close this
hearing for 2 38
and move on to the next hearing which is
a sb 381
this is a bill establishing the office
of advocate for special education
senator reagan who's been waiting so
patiently here is
here to present the bill
welcome
good morning chairman lead and house
education
just as a note on your last bill i
served on a commission
that investigated
the effectiveness of these agreements
between the school districts and the
charter schools
and it was
very encouraging
to see how well
all these adults got together and worked
out
problems with transportation
and
do we hire a teacher or do we share a
teacher
and so
all that was very encouraging
until
you people
last year
passed a bill that said we're going to
change who's responsible
for
what who's to who's bears the
responsibility
for
children with special needs
and
in this room we investigated that
and we heard from a lot of people
and we produced the four inch binder of
testimony and there wasn't a happy story
in the whole binder
so the binders at the office of
performance audit and oversight now
and they're developing a scope statement
for a performance audit of
how we're doing with special education
in the state
and that brings me to senate bill 381
and i'm senator john reagan from senate
district
17. and
i'm
quite happy to present
senate bill 3812. may i add one thing in
please senator for the committee this is
an early bill
this bill has to be out of this
committee this week
go ahead
okay
so
this bill establishes an office of the
advocate for special education
it's
the way is cleared to implement this
office
and there's a lot of discussion
about why
somebody else
isn't advocating for special education
students but there are a lot of people
who are charged with that responsibility
but
pages and pages of testimony
from
very upset parents
of special education students
tells us that we had to go somewhere
else
so what the study committee
did
was
decided to ask for a performance audit
of special education because we couldn't
get answers
and
left this with the idea for the special
advocate
so
that's
as that
previous
um school board
fella said
what's the intent of the legislation so
the intent of this legislation is to
have somebody
fielding
the problems
that are presented and often defeated
by law firms in the state of new
hampshire that have made it their
business
to defeat the parents of the special
education students
so
one pair of parents
have in
several years paid
over twenty three thousand dollars in
tuition
and they drive their daughter an hour
each way
every day to get to a school that is
meeting her needs
so that's
that was an expensive solution to the
problem
and then we met a we listened to a lot
of parents
that were
often in tears over what they had to say
about the treatment that they had
developing an iep
and having been
brow beaten
by a law firm
into and finally giving up
so that's pretty tough when
we have a pile of statutes federal and
state
that say you have to do something
you can't just abandon these children
and that's pretty much how the system
works now
if they're too costly or too much
trouble
or the parents aren't able
to
employ an attorney to come to the
meeting
they're just
just beaten down and they're not able to
help their children
but it's the law
we have to help their children
and i facetiously said at one point
why don't we just take these kids and
we'll just build another building out by
the state
prison and we'll just put them in there
and then we won't have to worry about
them they'll be fed clothed they'll be
housed and this is where they'll spend
the rest of their lives
and
i had too many people said
you're right
this is the solution if you're not going
to help them you might as well put them
somewhere where they're safe and other
people can be safe from them because
they're gonna too often
turn to crime for a way to make a living
because we're not giving them the tools
that we all enjoy
because of this
faulty system
so i appreciate what all the
well-meaning people in this business
say they're doing
but we've just got too many
lost children
and that's what
the office of the advocate for special
education
is designed to do
thank you very much senator uh i have
one one question for you we've received
correspondence from
the office of child advocate yes which
is a independent agency within
uh the department of administrative
services indicating that this bill
replicates duties
that's their responsibility that they
are performing do you see it the same
way no because we had no testimony that
anybody was assisted by the office of
the child advocate for special education
problems
and that was my answer to the former
child advocate
who decided it would be a good idea to
take this office
and give the money to the office of the
child advocate and let them have the
employees
and continue on
their not so successful mission
thank you are there questions from the
committee rep san luna sure thank you
very much mr chair thank you very much
senator reagan for bringing this forward
um you'd
towards the towards the conclusion of
your remarks you talked about um special
education students that had been
abandoned by their their district and
that's pretty strong statement i was
wondering if you could elaborate on
on that not getting into specific names
or specific districts but just in the in
the in the in your selection of the word
abandoned
um
you give provide a little context for
that well but the context would be that
the parents
knowing their child has a problem
and then goes to the school and say
i understand their services for
special needs children
and then they then proceed
through the process that exists now
and in the end
there's nothing available for their
children
yes
and and uh and thanks i i certainly
recognize i mean i think a number of us
have been on school boards and and
recognized that um that yeah parents are
certainly um
very um um you know connected and
engaged to advocate for their for their
children and that sometimes
disagreements do arise between a school
i'm sorry but i don't have the binder
that has all the testimony
and that's
those are very specific examples
representative mullen cordelli and lead
were the other members of the study
committee
thank you
further questions for senator reagan
uh representative woodcock thank you
everyone cordelia good morning i think i
think my question uh
i read through this a couple of times
i'm just trying to find
beyond the annual report and the annual
information in the metrics
what what is this person's actual power
to change something
the setup is that the advocate will
collect
all the information of everything that's
going on
and become the expert opinion
on behalf of the children
follow up mr chairman
thank you
um
okay so they advocate what what is it
they can actually do to change something
i imagine
i imagine we'll see reports coming out
of courtrooms
over what they're gonna have to do on
behalf of
the children okay thank you thank you mr
chairman
thank you very much mr chair
thank you senator for taking my question
can you explain to me
who this advocate will report to
the
it's an independent office
much
like the child advocate office
was created
so
i do i have a follow-up thank you so
uh they will be paid that office will be
paid out of tax payer funds correct
correct
thank you you're welcome representative
so do you see this predominantly
when a parent takes the school district
to court or do you see them acting
before that time with the school
district hopefully we'll learn where the
pitfalls are that don't allow
the special special needs children's to
receive services
so
this is a
a information gathering mission for the
advocate
thank you
for the question representative mullin
represented waltz thank you mr chair and
thank you senator for taking my question
um in the actual
hiring process uh the bill indicates
that the governor and council would
appoint somebody to this position
and it references experiences and
qualifications that would make them
appropriate for the job
can you elaborate a little bit more on
what those experiences and
qualifications might look like
i'm going to see that
idea and specification to the governor
and council
they're going to have to decide
where to find the best person for this
job
further representative waltz
thank you mr chairman so
i used to work for the us department of
education officer civil rights
and people all over the country who
thought that their
kids were not getting a free appropriate
public education these are parents of
special ed students could and did
complain to and i'm sure continue to
complain to the office for civil rights
and it and
it was a huge deal to investigate those
things and we had he there's 10 regional
offices there were huge staffs that went
in you'd send a whole team of
investigators in to do this this was no
simple thing to determine
whether a school district was providing
the most an appropriate education to a
special ed child
and and it appears that this office is
set up to address
concerns of individual parents not just
looking for patterns in school districts
of not providing faith
and i'm concerned as to how this could
possibly work and not just become a
place where every disgruntled parent in
the state goes and makes a complaint
whether the school district is at fault
or not and how this office at a budget
of five hundred thousand dollars could
possibly have the resources to deal with
the number of disgruntled parents in
this state
if you wanted to amend it to add money
i also serve on finance i know more than
that
as do i
further questions from the committee
thank you very much senator
i'd like to invite cassandra sanchez
from the office of the child advocate
good morning good morning chairman lad
i have copies of my
written testimony if that's
necessary do you have multiple copies
yes they do sure watch just hand them
out to representative ford right there
and he'll take care of it
thank you for this opportunity to meet
with you all
and i hope that we'll work together more
in the future
i was just confirmed to this position
last week so i'm brand new here i've
also brought with me emily lawrence from
the office to help with answering
questions
i do rely upon my full written testimony
as submitted but i will share some
highlighted points in the interest of
time
as you know the office of the child
advocate is an independent agency
mandated to provide oversight to state
and state arranged services to children
and promote children's best interest
i am here today
to speak in opposition to senate bill
381 establishing an office of the
advocate for special education as
written but would support the concept in
an amended version
senate bill 381 would establish an
independent independent agency
administratively attached to the
department of administrative services to
house an advocate for special education
the bill replicates current obligations
of the office of the child advocate
we do recognize the need for this role
but believe there is a solution without
redundancy and extra cost
the child advocate already has
jurisdiction over education and special
education with access to children's
educational records and other
information about children pursuant to
rsa 21v
well while i am only days into my role
as child advocate my understanding is
that the mandate over education is
relatively new
and that the office has not yet fully
mobilized to educate the public
including the legislature about our
expanded jurisdiction
we also lack the level of expertise that
senate bill 381 represents in a new
agency
we know that parents struggle to obtain
needed special education services for
their children and we are grateful for
all those parents here today and to
every day advocate for their children as
well as senator regan and the bill's
co-sponsors for recognizing the needs
for many children and families
too often the very manifestation of a
child special education qualifying
disability that has not been properly
assessed or addressed is the cause for
behavior that pro that prompts out of
home placements or adjudication for
delinquency enhancing resources to
assist children to access special
education services is in the best
interest of children in their optimal
development
it is also in the state's interest to
reduce unnecessary spending on children
receiving expensive deep-ended services
such as institutional care because of
unmet educational needs
in the senate committee of cognizance we
pointed out the redundancy of
legislation and recommended senate bill
381 be amended to place the advocate for
special education in the independent
office of the child advocate the primary
reason for this is the office's
jurisdiction over special education
under rsa 21b
we recognize that we have not yet fully
engaged individuals regarding assistance
with special education concerns this
shortcoming is viewed as an effect of
limited staffing and pandemic related
obstacles for community outreach
we further note that in the senate
education committee hearing rebecca
fradette director of special education
with the department of education
testified that the bill is redundant to
some of the functions the doe is
required to perform per federal law
she explained that since she has been in
the role for only a short time she is
working to ensure that the system and
services are
are being more responsive to families
placing the special education advocate
in the office of the child advocate
would bring that expertise and extra
manpower to provide outreach to families
and effective advocacy specific to
special education when needed
many children with comp complex special
education needs have other needs served
by multiple systems such as
developmental disabilities and
behavioral health services
and juvenile justice or child protective
services to that end the office of the
child advocate is already working with
many of the same families that would
benefit from
a special education advocate keeping all
advocates under one roof would situate
the special education advocate with
in-house supports and expertise in those
other specialty areas
creating a whole new agency would be
confusing for families already
navigating a complicated system a single
access for assistance navigating systems
and advocating for children eases the
burden of already frustrated parents
ultimately keeping the office of the
child advocate
keeping to one office the child advocate
would save the state considerable funds
as requested of the senate education
committee i provide a very basic
overhead cost of a new agency versus
enhancing the office of the child
advocate with extra staff
they represent a potential savings of
approximately three hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars from the
bill's fiscal note of five hundred
thousand dollars this estimate does not
include cost and workload burden for the
department of administrative services
who staff administer services for
administratively attached agencies
recognizing the need to follow the field
toward more prevention services to
manifest minimize child protection in
juvenile justice cases the office's
jurisdiction was expanded to all
children's services this expansion of
services is just over a year old
it is very timely that senate bill 381
was raised as a need for the specialized
resources recognized in the office of
the child advocate
for these reasons i urge you to amend
senate bill 381 and place the special
education advocate in the office of the
child advocate with an allocation of
funds for the position and one legal aid
to support the advocate thank you for
your time thank you very much i i do
have one question of a sort of follow-up
to your presentation
um
i received the email from you the other
day
and in it it says we also lack the
resident expertise and special education
law that would be most helpful to
children with complex needs
so the letter itself stating that you
don't have the
expertise in this area of special
education law then why is
why then are
is your organization then oppositional
to the direction of this bill
correct we do not which is why we
believe taking on the staff who have
that specialty to work alongside the
other advocates within the office would
be a better option as opposed to a
separate agency in itself
thank you
questions from the committee
representative luno then reps and lekkas
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much and congratulations on
your uh on your new role here in new
hampshire thank you um i was wondering
and sort of follow on to uh what what um
uh representative ladd
was uh was inquiring um you would you'd
you you talk about the um the sort of
the multiple dimensions of of the the
office of the child advocate and
certainly having to work with a number
of different uh parameters and um and
the sort of the i guess the the
specific needs of of different children
you know uh
and the different support
channels that exist in the state would
would incorporate incorporating special
education
under the office of the child advocate
improve the um the outcomes not just for
um for special edu where there's where
there's some disagreements with respect
to special education but also perhaps
for other children too by having that
expertise some uh you know under one
roof yes we do believe so because
we do have the expertise in regards to
children with mental health difficulties
and behavioral health struggles so
incorporating the special education
which is often a crossover with where we
see a lot of behavioral needs having
that all in one house and sharing the
expertise with the person who will bring
in an
expertise and special education would
optimize our ability to serve all
families
thank you representative
thank you
i'm just trying to
think about how this works
can you tell me
if a parent or well let's say if a child
needs an advocate
who pays for the advocate
not meaning in working with our office
whether it's yeah whether i mean whether
it's the special whether it will be the
special needs advocate or whoever
an advocate that's assigned to the child
who pays for the
who pays who pays that
does the state does the parent who does
that so within our agency we have staff
that are paid through the state and
those staff
screen calls um handle complaints and
and they would be in in this case also
having the special education advocate
along with a legal aid would be able to
be the contact paid through the state
with the budget proposed
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative cardelli
thank you mr chairman
thank you for being here and
congratulations
on the new position
welcome to new hampshire thank you um
uh
just wondering about your
statement about
approximately a year ago those mandate
um expansion for uh to include education
and and looking at the statute i i
really see that it looks like the
current responsibilities of the um
office are centered on
child welfare and juvenile justice
so i'm
maybe a little confused about where the
education responsibility
comes in
absolutely so
with that expansion we were able to have
oversight of all agencies that serve as
children across the state which is which
would encompass education as well so we
have access to the records and the
ability to communicate with schools on
behalf of children
further questions
yes representative ellison
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question just
maybe some details from you on
how this person the advocate would
function going back to the previous
discussion about
who are they responsible to
what is the outcome of let's say they
they're dealing with
deal with a number of cases
uh they
whatever decide that this has happened
this has happened this has happened what
is the
what effect is that of is of that
information where i'm actually asking
what is the impact of what this person
could actually do within the systems
sure much like the office of the child
advocate there within our office they
would fit in a similar role um with the
ability to
collect the data process the data work
on complaints with families and then
take this back to meetings with the
special education department meetings
with legislature about other legislation
that impact special special education
for children
so they would have a very similar role
to mine now but specific to special
education
thank you thank you representative
porter
thank you mr chair and welcome thank you
so i'm a little confused about the word
advocate
in my mind if if i were a parent
and i had a child with learning
disabilities and i felt that they
weren't getting what they needed
and an advocate came to help me i would
think
that that advocate might be coming to
the iep meetings with me and helping me
understand the law and that sort of
thing but i'm getting the idea
from what i'm hearing now that that's
not what the office would do the office
would be more
checking into things and making reports
so that things could get fixed am i
right in my second
yes we would not have the resources to
have staff attending all iep meetings we
would be able to help educate parents on
rights and how to proceed and we would
also be able to point them in the
direction of other resources that
already exist within special education
that they may not be aware of that could
help on more of that direct level
tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question so does the advocate then
become an expert witness and or give the
parent uh legal
advice or information that they can then
bring to
any kind of
adjudication of their concerns
i don't believe um i don't believe so
because currently with under the child
advocate law it does not state that we
can be involved in any court involvement
um you know being an expert witness is
not included in the role so no
thank you for your question
further questions from the committee
reps and
hall thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um
before i gather the parent information
center
pick that the parents use do they pay
for that service do you know that the
child advocate
yes do they have to pay when they want
an advocate and they go to the parent
information center is that something
they personally are responsible for
paying um or is it free something i'm
entirely clear on but i believe there is
federal funding for some of that so i
think some of it is covered
but i can get back to you with an answer
on that okay great thank you
yeah
yeah we have to make sure people are
using the mic when they speak i'm sorry
are there further questions
representative moffitt
thank you mr thank you for being here
welcome aboard uh quickly um i i
certainly you you got my our attention
when you mentioned the 317 000 savings
but again this is a policy committee so
back to policy and i know you're new uh
but perhaps somebody uh i know
representative mullen rip some cordelia
rip some loud apparent and
senator reagan have already dealt with
this my question is are you aware of
success or not success
with this type of position in other
states are there models out there that
we could look at
i'm not familiar with the specific
special education advocate utilized in
other states i am aware of other states
like our proposition here uh choosing to
have
a specialist within the office of the
child advocate that assists with special
education needs
uh
so what you just said then is the notion
of this position being rolled into
an existing position that model is out
there you in other states
is what i'm hearing yes
okay thank you
further question represent hobson
thank you mr chair and welcome to new
hampshire thank you for taking my
question i was just wondering if i don't
know if i missed it um your letter was
pretty uh
information packed can you tell me do
you know how many positions you might be
looking to hire thank you
yes so we would be looking for two
positions one being the special
education advocate and the other being a
legal aid to assist with the advocates
role
further questions
not yes representative ford
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
several times as we've talked about
these kinds of issues
we've gotten to this point where we've
been talking about someone
gathering information
and perhaps you heard just a little bit
before when people got a little
frustrated because they were looking for
an answer from the senator
and i suspect the same is from you but
i'd like you to confirm or deny that
what happens when you get to a point
where you're aware of something which
might even be illegal
what then do you do
and that's what we're not hearing
with this it's just sort of what we know
about it
well we're more interested in what are
you going to do about it
or what are you authorized to do about
it if it's not anything i understand
that but
we need to know that
absolutely so what we would look to do
with this role is we would look to
collect the data like i said follow the
trends put out reports on this so that
it is aware we'd look to have connection
meetings with the
special education department on a
consistent basis to talk about these
issues
to talk about resolutions to these
issues we could make recommendations for
solutions once we have some data and
some reviews and then also bring things
to the legislative table if we feel that
they
you know advocate for change if we feel
it's not being addressed at special
education level we have the data then to
back what we would look to change in
legislature
thank you
further questions of the
office of
oh yes go ahead representative yeah
thank you very much mr chair and um
thanks for taking um my question would
um
just sort of following on the you know
the conversation about about you know
folding this in underneath the office of
the child advocate given your existing
uh expanded authority would this need to
be done
this being the ability to hire a special
education advocate and the legal support
staff
under
under the office of child advocate would
this need
new legislation
or could this be done through
through let's say the budget process
thank you for the question i believe
this could be done through the budget
process since we already have
jurisdiction over this area
it would be a matter of just folding in
these new positions
thank you further questions i have one
follow-up
uh i've worked with this office before
when we're talking about
individuals which are incarcerated in
one of the uh
institutions we have here within the
state up in grafton county
uh where a student was a person was
under age 21 had an active iep
and was not being served
in terms of though of regular education
does your office
have authority to access educational
records
of
any student
or do you have to be first contacted to
have that right to access records
so under the statute it allows us to
access edu it says education records so
typically we wouldn't just access a
record unless someone contacts us but we
we don't necessarily need to um
under the law we have that permission to
access i'm familiar with that area of
statute i was just curious to know how
that worked though in terms of
saying i want to go and look at this
file this student
can you do that without parental
permission
sure the um we currently can with dcyf
records to be honest we have not
had the opportunity to go
look at case records specifically at a
school
but it is our understanding that we
would be able to do so
and we do not have to seek permission
for example with
the same with gcyf
thank you
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm going to ask you
the same question that i asked senator
reagan
if you were to be hiring for this
position how would you go about or what
kind of criteria would you use to
determine
who has uh appropriate experience and
qualifications
yes so
we would be looking for somebody who has
a background in special education for a
specific length of time um but
especially if they have had the
opportunity to be on the advocacy end
you know whether previously enrolled as
an advocate or having actually done the
front line work of advocating so we
would be looking for that background and
we would also use the assistance of our
oversight commission in that hiring
process
are there further questions
thank you very much thank you like to
call forward kate shay
good morning committee kate shane
goffstown
thank you for hearing me chairman and
esteem committee i just wanted to say a
few words this morning i'm here
representing families of new hampshire
and i'm going to keep this short as i
have to run to another meeting i'm one
of your typical special needs parents
that's trying to fit in everything for
my kids and to advocate for them
including being here today because not
that it affects them directly anymore i
think i shared with the committee last
time i was here three of them are now
out of school doing other alternative
school options
and you know i think there's a few
different arguments i want to cover one
is i think we want kids in school right
i think we can all agree to that we want
kids in school being part of the system
getting the supports and services that
they need right
and the people of new hampshire spoke
really clearly on this bill
several months ago maybe even a year ago
700 people signed a petition
for this bill and felt it was that
important
and i have to tell you having advocated
for families in the state now because of
my kids
that it's a very precarious position you
put yourself in when you stick your neck
out and you sign a petition like that
it comes with retaliation
that might blow some people's minds but
that's the life that we live when our
kids are in special education in this
state we are regularly retaliated
against and we had people 700 people
sign this put their names to it so i
would multiply that many times over when
you're considering the amount of family
need for this
what i didn't hear with the last couple
speakers was going back to why we're
here we felt that an independent party
boy and those those that word really
rings and means a lot to me independent
independence
independent party was needed for this
role
why would that be well i heard
grow resources
uh work with special educators
redundancy jurisdiction lacking
pandemic
where are families in all of this
that's one thing that really jumped out
i didn't hear anything about families
i am the voice the families and i sit
here and i imagine
a slew of you know army of parents
behind me when i come to speak because i
fit it in between the little time that i
have
and i hope that that carries a lot of
weight because i do feel it's important
to be here and to say we're leaving
families out of the equation we don't
need another pick we don't need another
disability rights center we've had these
solutions we've tried them they don't
work because 381 said that they didn't
work right so if we want kids in schools
then we need to look what services they
need in the eye and provide faith which
is according to federal law a free and
appropriate education we are not doing
that in the state today so to talk about
funding and we'd need more money and
you know gosh if we get a class action
lawsuit all this goes out the window
okay texas had that happen
i'd hate to see that happen here but
that snowball has been building over
time and it will eventually happen if we
don't address this in the right way
so when i hear about
another agency or another
group that's going to grow itself the
first of all there's a lacking level of
expertise here that stood out to me you
know when you're talking about the
office of child advocate and i can tell
you this from firsthand experience i
came through a six-year marathon divorce
in the great state of new hampshire and
i paid for a guardian ad litem
i figured they would understand special
needs we're not talking anything too
rocket science here we're talking about
autism things like that do you know that
in the final report not any of the
plethora of evidence that i provided
from medical doctors in boston was taken
into any consideration
and that's that's just one experience of
many where this happens all the time
we're not talking about kids that need
residential or institutional care we're
talking about your average child that
now about 1 in 20 has neurodiversity and
neurodiverse needs the rigid school
settings aren't a good match for that so
we're talking about 30 minutes of speech
30 minutes of occupational therapy a
week you know something very basic
and i also heard this group isn't going
to be in iep meetings so if you're not
even going to be in iep meetings how are
you possibly going to understand what's
going on in these cases
so i share my own you know
uh situation with the gio because
obviously there wasn't enough bandwidth
for this person to even understand
how i broke down i made timelines i had
everything you name it they didn't take
the time to do any of that homework
so
you know i think that there's a
danger here that we need to be very
careful of a mindful of that we're
already in a situation where
neurodiversity is on the rise
there is a risk of overreach
with people that are not trained so we
run into this today already in schools
with a school psychologist maybe who has
minimal minimal training trying to come
up with a diagnosis
they shouldn't be diagnosing right
they're not medical professionals and
because of this bill
and actually the burden of proof we got
a little bit of consideration along the
lines of the fact that these are not
medical professionals they should not be
diagnosed in kids
so i would say the same applies to an
office of the advocate how can they
possibly understand something that it
takes medical doctors years and years
and years to understand and go to school
for and
you know so there is a danger of
overreach there's a danger of the risk
of understanding the complexities
we already have protections for
districts i heard you know special
educators but i didn't hear families
so you're talking about now commingling
child's education records
you're allowing them access to things
you know and this growing bureaucracy
will very easily have a way i mentioned
retaliation the beginning
you bet retaliation can happen it just
now opens the door and makes it 10 times
more easy for that to happen
and these aren't kids that need you know
i'm not talking about kids in the sununu
center kids with behavioral issues if
they have them it's because they have
underlying medical needs that weren't
addressed
so you know budget aside you know
whoever does this aside we need to do
the right thing here for families listen
to the families that brought this up to
begin with
and we don't need more health and human
services folks and lawyers bottom line
so with that i appreciate your time
today do you have any questions thank
you very much are there any questions
representatives
so ideally what would you like to see
created
for the children
i could tell you it would be you know
and i did see this
solution come about as the bill evolved
and you know as i mentioned there my
hackles went up a little bit when i
heard about more another office right
i do think there can be merits to
something like that i think it's the way
it's approached i work in software
engineering i hire people all the time
that are very you know they're for very
specific needs and levels of experience
so i would say it it's dependent on you
know the success of that role and that
that position is dependent upon who you
get for that right it all comes down to
people
and i think you need to listen to
families and look at what are the set of
things that you know as we become
experts as parents even in our own kids
needs
heck we're we're actually experts in a
lot of this too you know and i'm not
suggesting you hire a parent per se but
i would say we need to keep that
balanced with not just reaching into the
pool of the same old same old that we go
to but look at it a little bit
differently and maybe um
a little more radically even be a little
more progressive in our thinking about
who we'd want to hire for that
shouldn't be the same old cookie cutter
approach
i hope that answers your question
thank you you're welcome thank you uh
representative tanner
uh thank thank you and thank you for
coming today and just as kind of a
follow-up to representative lakers's
idea you had mentioned something about
um that they need to be able to go to an
iep meeting and it seems like a lot of
the frustration is that parents don't
feel as though they have an equal
footing with
the school district than the lawyers and
and just them
um and i think we've had other bills
that have come through that have tried
to balance that out a little bit
um and so unless you had a
office of like 500 people
that could go out uh you know or
deputize them to go out it just in my
mind i'm i'm trying to
from hearing you and
you know my heart goes out to you but
how how do you see this being
implemented
uh on on the to help the the family you
know because you're advocating at that
level right well and i'm happy to follow
up with testimony and i'm going to send
everybody the copies of the petition
whatnot but i also put together a flow
chart at one point in time that
describes the process so i think there's
some points of failure in the process
and one that really bothers me in
particular is
and this will tie back to the number of
meetings so
it isn't humanly possible for someone to
go to all these meetings right no it's
just not going to happen but i do think
that someone should be seeing these
meetings because for someone like myself
that's in software engineering and
process re-engineering
it's very easy to see along the spectrum
of the key decisions that are made and
the points that decisions need to be
made where this gets dragged out
indefinitely and that's done a lot of
times on purpose
frankly and you have 10 meetings instead
of one meeting so i think that a
successful advocate could be involved
right up front in the process we also
need to look at
there's a part of
vape or rather the idea process that
talks about that schools only need to
consider
documentation on a medical diagnosis and
that to me is a real sticking point
because if i'm coming in with boston
children's hospital diagnosis of autism
or whatever and i've gone through
thousands of dollars to get this child
diagnosed done my done my job as a
parent right jump through hoops then
that should be more than just considered
right
but the wording of some of these things
is such that that allows the process
just keep going and keep going keep
going so there's inefficiencies in the
process itself and some of those
unfortunately are tied to idea and
federal law and some things that we need
to change
but i do think that we should be
empowered as a state to make some of
those changes ourself and implement
differences in process where we can come
to agreement earlier on right and get
those 30 minutes of speech to that child
sooner like
we're
you know if you look at the
inefficiencies of the whole thing it's
just we're spending exponential amounts
of money just arguing with each other
right and if we just did the right thing
up front
that would save all the rest of that so
to answer your question no you can't be
in every iep meeting you can't even be
to every child's one iep meeting but i
think we need to make a better attempt
of really seeing what's happening and
actually you know i would invite all of
this committee go check out an iep
meeting sit in one sometime and and
you'll easily see where there's
inefficiency
so i hope that answers your question
yes
it it kind of does and kind of does
so i was a teacher for a long time so i
sat on a lot of iep meetings as as the
teacher and saw
what you see
sometimes um
and it seems like what you're asking for
is
different legislation to set a different
you know set of protocols and and the
way things are handled
i'm just wondering how a five hundred
thousand dollar
independent office
is going is going to do that i mean
we've tried to do that with with the
department of education
um you know the child advocacy group is
now trying to look into that with
what what areas they kind of specialize
in but it doesn't seem
to me that this particular bill hits
what you want it to and i'm just
wondering
if you see that as well
it's a start in the right direction
families have no power right now pretty
much
and teachers i would say are in the same
boat okay so i recently ran for school
board in my town and that was one of the
messages that came really loud and clear
through to the teachers and i had them
many of them vote for me and it was
because they can't say anything
they're bound by and you would know that
sitting in those meetings they have to
toe the line to what administration
wants them to do they can't just speak
out and say you know what i think we
should just do this
um i think this is a start it is not
going to
you know resolve all of the issues that
we have right now but if we do nothing
we fall back on
really lives being ruined and i can tell
you i testified in another committee and
quoted the old i'm not catholic but the
catholic church has a saying about if
you you know lay the foundation for a
child by the time they're eight
then that child is going to have a good
footing in life for their morals and
their ethics all that kind of stuff the
same is to be said here
we don't start to solve these problems
you're going to have entire generations
of dependent people on the state of new
hampshire
i can promise that
so it's not going to solve everything
overnight but it needs to be the right
independent office it needs to be the
right person or set of people
and i think you know as i tell my kids
you know you use your mind you use your
imagination the sky's the limit why
can't we do that here
it's a start it's better than nothing
thank you further questions
representatives
could you um
send to us
a
list of the
failure points that you see commonly
happening
sure i'd be happy and your flow
yeah absolutely thank you yeah it just
um as somebody in the professional world
of you know 20 plus years
it kind of boggled my mind and one of my
mom advocates is sitting behind me more
here so i got here because other parents
throw each other lifelines
so the process flow
finally at some point i said where i'm
going to sit down and put this process
flow together and pinpoint where we've
got problems because it blew my mind as
a professional sitting through these
meetings and one day actually somebody
said well we're going to have to have
another meeting i said aren't we in a
meeting or you know i mean if any of you
have professional work lives you would
appreciate this right it's like the visa
commercial the cost of whatever and then
they get to the end of it says priceless
the cost of just getting this done is
priceless and it's not just priceless
because of the price tag it's because
there's a little face
that you're going to be helping or not
helping
so i'll send you the flow chart i'm
happy to share it with anybody i wish i
could get more points across here but
we can we can do this you know and that
was my message with the school board and
with the teachers
this is this is pro teacher okay we want
kids in schools right
three of mine are out because they
couldn't get their needs met and out not
meaning not in school but in different
options
we want them in schools don't we
so with that i thank you all if you have
any questions thank you very much
um seeing no more hands thank you very
much
thank you
uh christine
metz
m-e-t-z
ari
metzner okay
good morning mr chair lad and committee
representatives
my name is christine metzner and i live
in ryan new hampshire i'm here to
support sb 381
and my experience with my son's 504
plans and in the iep process
demonstrates the need i believe for a
special education advocate here in new
hampshire i have this three inch binder
it's overflowing with emails letters
plans notices meeting notes
are corrections to meeting notes
doctor's letters
updated doctor's letters and it just
covers 14 months
so i think as i go through this it might
highlight some of the failure points in
these processes
when my son was 10 he developed a
neuroimmune condition and among his many
symptoms were extreme anxiety
agoraphobia sensory issues and cognitive
regressions as if it was as if he had a
traumatic brain injury but his symptoms
progressively got worse
when he was in sixth grade we developed
a 504 plan and later wound up in the iep
process now i'm a lawyer by training i'm
not presently practicing and i
familiarize myself with these laws and
especially for the iep process it took
hours to begin to understand the
framework of the system i was
overwhelmed and i turned to an advocate
and later a lawyer for help
i made it clear to the school what i
believed would help my son
some home tutoring because his
agoraphobia was so bad he could not
leave the house
we had meetings multiple meetings that
my son's psychologist attended but they
couldn't say yes or no in my request
i finally resorted to hiring a lawyer
which made the school start having a
lawyer attend the meetings but once i
hired a lawyer my simple request for a
home tutor a couple hours a week was
magically granted
this was four weeks and three meetings
after i first made the request
the tutors came to our house for about
two months until the end of the school
year
my son probably had about 20 hours of
two-day tutoring
and that was all of his public education
for the last six months of his sixth
grade year i'm sure they'll and
you can tell the lawyers made more money
than the tutors not to mention the hours
of administrator and teacher times
come september the school would not
allow further tutoring
by my request recommendations from my
son's providers his doctors his
psychologists
he was starting to do better could leave
the house uh was also very fatigued so
he was on a very part-time schedule
and
they just would not agree to tutoring
until we finished the iep valuation
process
so
when we signed the consent to the
evaluations 60 days passed
no word from the evaluators
so we agreed the school asked for an
extension
30 days later still no completed
evaluations i never heard from one of
the school's evaluators and the school's
chosen psychiatrist
never contacted my son's providers for
the information he needed
at this point there'd be been a total of
nine 504 in iep meetings my son's
psychologist was at six of these
meetings and my lawyer and the school's
lawyers were at five of
them meanwhile my school was getting two
hours of education a week at school
we finally decided to homeschool our son
he was not getting free in appropriate
education and although the school didn't
necessarily abandon him
the school was kicking the can down the
road
while i was homeschooling my son i was
shocked by how many people are
homeschooling their children because of
the difficulties they face in bible
chores or ieps there's not even
statistics on that nobody keeps that in
the state
parents of children who need
accommodations or services need an
office to turn to for help
i mentioned earlier that i'm a lawyer by
training the procedural safeguards
aren't written in plain english and i
had trouble understanding that i hired
an advocate then a lawyer
and if i needed him
imagine a single mother with a full-time
job and children with significant
educational needs or someone for whom
english is not a first language
you know schools are spending more and
more on legal fees my own siu has talked
about increasing legal expenses
in their budget because they see a trend
of advocate outreach by parents i'm not
sure what else parents are supposed to
do the trade schools get so much
training from law firms
and there's no reason for them to hire a
lawyer for individual 504s and ieps
i've seen no indication that schools are
asking why parents are seeking more help
parents don't fully understand the
process they don't feel heard and are
quite likely up
overwhelmed
uh i'd like to address the uh
position of the office of the child
advocate
one thing i
think about here often is that the
office of the child advocate as i
understand it was too created to provide
assistance for children
in cases of abuse or neglect or in the
juvenile justice system primarily
that doesn't there might be some overlap
with special education
i would be shocked
if
i don't believe there's a majority of
children who need special education and
the office of
the special education advocate who also
have children in the dcyf system and in
fact i actually sort of see that as a
conflict of interest i don't know how
the office of the child advocate
would address those situations and um
especially the office of the child
advocate is for
people
parents families who are trying
to do the right thing for their children
um i'm happy to say that my son is now
quite a bit better he's improved
substantially he's returned to public
school and he's now thriving as a
sophomore
anybody has any questions and i do have
my written testimony thank you very much
are there any questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
like to uh invite jane brugerone
morning for the record my name is jane
bertrand and i am the executive director
for the new hampshire association of
special education
administrators and i will um keep my
comments uh brief my written testimony
is going around you'll see from our
testimony that we we do recognize the
importance of this kind of an office but
would respectively raise several
questions and concerns the first point
that we want to bring forward is that
the new hampshire department of ed
currently has a process
for investigating special education
complaints
and
currently there really is no real
evidence that this process
um is not being provided and that the
department is failing to do their job in
terms of investigations and i'm sure the
department can give you specifics on the
the numbers of complaints that come
forward and
how they are reviewed and dealt with
the second
point that we want to bring forward is
that idea
makes each state agency responsible for
the oversight
of
services to kids with disabilities
and we don't see that there's a need to
have a duplicate office for that and and
feel that new hampshire
is sufficiently meeting those needs in
terms of the oversight of services
provided to students with disabilities
we also want to point out that currently
the bureau of special education is
understaffed there's only one position
within the bureau that's state funded
the rest of the positions our
federally funded
and would raise the question as to
whether or not those resources that are
in this bill whether or not they should
be dedicated and directed towards the
bureau of special education to enhance
their current processes and procedures
um
we also brought forward several other
questions within the testimony in
regards to some of the specific language
and some of that has already been
mentioned
in closing we would say that you know in
general we feel as though this bill just
recreates a duplicate system for one
that alway already exists in new
hampshire so i would uh open it up for
any questions that you might have
thank you very much are there any
questions
not representative
i'm hearing conflicting things here you
said everything is being handled the
people are all doing what they're
supposed to and yet we have lots of
parents coming in saying it's not being
handled
and so
do you have a sense as to
why this dichotomy
thank you for the question and i think
that's a good one and i would suggest
that we really dig deeper at the data
and the number of disgruntled parents
versus those who are satisfied and
really looking at what some of the
critical issues are
i would say that the vast majority of
parents in the state are satisfied
um and uh if there are it's you know
areas in which we need to improve we're
certainly open to doing that
and would would really suggest that we
dig a little bit deeper at the data we
heard this morning about the large
binder of of complaints and would really
say you know how many
parents are those and and no parent
should ever be
disgruntled and no child should ever not
get their services and we're willing to
deal with that
but to bring forward legislation on
small numbers
we may want to look more closely at that
thank you you're welcome
are there further questions
not seeing it yeah
so thanks very much mr chair thanks very
much jane for taking my question just a
real quick one just so we can put this
in context
approximately how many special children
are um
receiving special education services in
new hampshire i think becky could really
give us the specifics but i think it's
around 17 of the our student population
yeah so that would be around the 30 to
35 000. i believe it's that's right
around that number thank you
those are the numbers which we have
it's usually hovering right around 30
plus thousand of students dollars
okay further questions did you have your
hand up
thank you thank you very much and thank
you
um
i was just thinking the same thing
actually when we're hearing that there's
a petition of at least 700 people that
sounds significant um but i i suppose
putting in perspective with 30 to 35 000
i can see both sides i'm just curious if
anyone has taken
or had the chance to dig into the data
to see if maybe there are certain
districts
that we're running into issues with more
so than others and maybe that needs to
be addressed versus legislation
and again i think that would be
something the department of education
could uh answer there they they're the
ones that deal with uh complaints
and could probably give you more
information on that
thank you
further questions
now thank you very much thank you
mariah ryan
good morning mr chairman
and committee members
my name is maura ryan and i'm a parent
advocate and a parent of a child
currently in school who has special
needs who has autism
um i want to sort of answer some of the
questions 700 people on a petition is
significant because of the incredible
retaliation that parents get when they
don't agree with the school district
i also wanted to address that ocr can
only take a complaint for 180 days which
passes in the blink of an eye and a due
process hearing only goes back two years
which is even less than what we allow
for our court procedures which is a
minimum of three years
i also wanted to add
that
we had a parent survey done by the
department of education which indicated
a lack of satisfaction with special
education services and it's well known
nationally that special education
services are not on par with where they
should be
in our particular state over 97 percent
of the students who are in the iep pool
have normal range iqs
less than three percent have um
developmental and intellectual disabil
disabilities
um
so they should be capable
of maintaining
proper academic records and be
employable however that's not the case
and that gets shown in the proficiency
scores which are in single digits right
now
for right now students with ieps are
less than 10 for both reading and math
as for the parent information center the
parent information center can provide
free consultations to parents to talk
about some of the issues that they're
facing but they don't attend iep
meetings and they don't get involved in
due process they do have an advocate on
staff who will charge a parent 30 an
hour to go in and they will do a file
record review a file record review is
where they read the review and they make
recommendations and what happens is the
parent goes into the meeting
lists the recommendations and the school
says oh well we don't really have to do
that which is very frustrating to the
parent because they've just spent 30
dollars times 20 hours for a file review
which seems like it's not it's a
significant chunk of money for a parent
particularly who doesn't have those
resources
it's been nationally recognized that
special education has been
a challenge for our country there are
other countries that are doing far
better my son is now 18 my cousin has a
kid who's five years younger than my son
who already speaks five languages and is
more proficient in academics because she
lives in our home country
and her and their education system is
better geared towards dealing with
children with disabilities
we need this person i support sb 381 we
need this person to be an independent
special education literate person
special education is a very very
specialized field i know a lot of about
special education because i've been
breathing it 24 7 365 for 18 years
that's a long time i mean i had to get
up at five o'clock in the morning i
drive my son between three different
schools he has 12 different doctors all
of whom i manage so it's overwhelming
enough for me to deal with the basic
aspects of his care in addition to which
i have to become a special education
expert
it's important to note also
that special education complaints on the
federal idea part b increased 500
percent last year 500 percent
um many parents came and spoke out about
the problems that they were having in
the 581 committee and it's very
difficult for them to come and try and
come up here find parking
come up and you know many parents work
because they have to pay for therapies i
know that in particular i've paid for
organ gillingham for my son for at least
seven years to a total probably about
seventy thousand dollars
um which is something he should be
getting at school that is what he's
entitled to
um my son attends school in manchester
and there's a colleague of mine luis
maldonado who posted on facebook why is
it that i have to have a lawyer involved
in every aspect of my child's special
education process
when does it end
and the the truth is it never ends it
never ends
um
shannon bouchard was someone who i was
trying to help and she wrote to several
of you because she contacted the office
of the child advocate and she got a
blow-off email in response and was told
to write to a general email and she
never got help her kid's been out of
school for almost the entire school year
there are people who have written entire
thesis
on how school districts can
cheat certain parents single mothers
people of color
low-income families military families
cheat them out of their kids special
education needs and the end result is
that almost the
almost 20 percent population of kids who
are on ieps are coming out
not capable of holding employment and
not fully educated because schools
follow the de minimis standard which is
basically the very very basic bare
minimum so you have 20 members of this
committee if you that would mean that
almost four of you would be un incapable
of functioning on this committee
incapable of living by yourself and
incapable of being fully functionally
literate
there are certain disabilities that have
not been dealt with effectively because
their newer autism in particular is one
of them
rebecca ferdet said the increase in
cases of autism in our state have
increased
666 percent and yet school districts
still do not know how to deal with
autism
medical science is advancing faster than
educational policy is and they're
becoming better at adapting kids to
their environments than school systems
are and the problem is that medical
science is getting completely
disregarded by the educational school
system
i think the five hundred thousand
dollars to establish this independent
office is a drop in the bucket compared
to the millions that will be spent
supporting the almost 20 percent of the
population that will not pay taxes and
will not be able to be functional my son
right now got a 28 on his a.c.t has a
genius level iq and he is not able to
function academically in school has no
future in college and cannot hold a job
and he should be able to
so my
ask is that you support this bill
because we the parents want an
independent educational advocate
we feel that this is necessary because
the system is not working and the proof
is in the proficiency scores and the
proof is in what parents write to you
and the proof is in all these pages
where parents are saying where is the
help
our kids are not getting their education
thank you very much are there any
questions
from the committee
thank you
we have one card left that's rebecca
ferdet from the department uh is there a
need for any
technical input from the
committee okay rebecca thank you you're
welcome
good morning again
may i represent life
go ahead thank you um
during the testimony we heard uh from
different uh people uh about the special
ed
doe
and the process some are saying there is
a process there is a
there is a step process for you folks
down there to take uh parents concerned
issues non-compliance in their opinion
and follow the way up and adjudicate
that some way and then we're hearing
it's not so can you just tell us in a
very brief format yeah we're required by
idea to have a dispute resolution
process and we do have one um it
includes complaints and it includes due
process hearings as well as mediation we
also provide iep facilitation to
districts and i do have numbers on
complaints and due process if you wanted
those i know that was a question
yep um so the the fault that then so if
i am a parent
uh
that we heard this morning if they'd
gone if they go through your process at
a doe yep uh somewhere something is
resolved
typically yes yes if they go through one
one of those processes there is a res
there was a always either a it's
dismissed or a resolution to
a complaint or a due process hearing yes
okay thank you representative you're
welcome rep santa luna
thank you very much mr chair thank you
thank you very much miss verdet for for
joining us so um so when when uh when
the department looks at uh looks at
complaints
do um do you look to spot trends that
might um might exist yes we do so um i
work closely with natasha lupiani who is
the complete person and we will uh we
will discuss whether there are trends of
certain districts or if there are
certain things certain types of
complaints that we're getting so that we
can address those complaints either
globally to all of the special education
directors or targeted to a specific
district
we do have a very small number of
complaints each year so it's it's hard
to find a trend with only 34 complaints
each year
yes you may and so so so based on
spotting trends and based on the um the
corrective action uh recommendations
that you that you that you make
have um has has that uh in in i guess
the cases where you've been concerned um
uh
addressed those those trends and and and
brought the numbers say
you know more um you know to what you
would expect
so our numbers for complaints and due
process are pretty consistent from year
to year even even over last year with
the pandemic we still are right around
the same number of complaints each year
so we haven't seen a drop or an increase
in those complaints
representative porter
thank you thank you so how many what's
your consistent number of complaints you
so so this year we have 34 complaints
i'm just going to pull it up because i
have it on my screen i apologize
so this year we had 34 complaints for
fiscal year 21. um nine of them were
withdrawn or dismissed 25 of them did
have a decision and of those 25 15 of
them were found findings of
non-compliance so that would be where
the district was found to be
non-compliant thank you
represent tanner did you have your hand
up
basically i wanted the statistics like
representative porter um what happens
when the when the school is found in
non-compliant is that corrected yep so
they're given when they are found
non-compliant compliant they're given a
letter of correction that is developed
with natasha um diana fenton and the
commissioner and a decision is made as
to how they will correct that and if
there is anything else that needs to be
done um regarding that complaint and
just does it follow up
is there any kind of satisfaction survey
that or survey like exit
survey
from the parents to say how they felt
the
the uh you know the whole thing was
handled no there isn't currently thank
you
as a follow-up to that we had a survey
provided the group that was looking at
this
um from the department uh could you
provide a copy of that survey to all
members of this committee um are you
referencing the 603 british future
survey survey that has the indicator
eight portions of it
well i i
it's that must be it you know i haven't
i have a copy but i don't know indicator
it is our family engagement portion and
we include it in the 603 bright future
service yes yes that's it yep i can give
you i can send those um those numbers to
you yes okay and the last question i
have for you and maybe it's best
directed towards the senator but um
we have a performance audit going on at
this point in time uh
do you have any idea where we are on
that are we nearing
some point
okay
wow we're at the top side of it
further questions of the department yes
represent lekkas
does the department do something to make
sure that all special needs students
know
of what you can do what you provide etc
because it seems they're like there's
much bigger than 34.
with
you know a large number of parents who
were unhappy
but you're only seeing a small number of
cases and i'm wondering
where that breakdown is and why you have
parents who aren't being helped
but you're not seeing them
so um currently we
we require that the districts provide
pros excuse me procedural safeguards to
each parent which offers them all of
those
kind of outlines all of those for them
but after the hearings this summer and
then the senate hearing earlier we have
been in the process of developing parent
trainings that we're going to be
providing about how to do different
processes within um the department so
that is something that's on our radar
and we're in the process of developing
thank you
thank you representative mullen
thank you mr chair i almost
almost missed my opportunity
thank you ms verdet for taking my
question
in fielding the
complaints
do you have a sense of
whether or not complaints generally
center around
parents wanting more than school
districts are offering and if so
how would a school district determine
where that line was
so
the our complaints are kind of um
widely varying there's no there's no
like i had said there's such a small
portion that to find trends um we do we
did find trends during the pandemic of
lots of complaints or calls around
masking and things like that and then
you may find complaints about whether
services were provided during the
pandemic but typically it's kind of a it
depends on where the student is who the
student is who the parent is it's not a
consistent
there's no
with such a small number there's no
consistent pattern that we see that that
we could pull from to to try to get some
of that addressed
unfortunately
thank you mr chair just the second part
of my question then without the first
part how do districts
determine
that
one child is going to get 10 hours of
reading and or math assistance and
another one
is only going to get four sure so each
student has to have a um annual
evaluation by
three year evaluation and so within that
evaluation they should be
reviewing what the students areas of
need are and what their strengths are
and then from there they would determine
the services
once you've determined those services
from that evaluation each year they're
supposed to provide
quarterly or
trimester progress reports to tell how
the student is doing and progressing on
those skills that you've targeted that
were identified in the evaluation so
through those three years you target
those skills you work on those skills
and provide progress reports so it's
pretty scripted about how you become
eligible um what your what the
eligibility requirements are and then
once you've done all of those
evaluations you should be using your
evaluations to determine services and
what the child needs to address their
needs
thank you very much are there any
further questions representatives
this is sort of a technical question as
you were explaining this
both i experienced with my granddaughter
but i also have heard lots of other
parents say the same thing is that
a child has specific needs
they get an iep
they're being provided those needs they
do better
and because they're now doing above a
certain performance in school it's
determined that they
don't need an iep and don't need those
needs but it was those special things
they were getting that allowed them to
do better how does that all work so the
team should be discussing that and
should be saying will this student
continue to be successful if we take
away those supports or does the child
need to be and have those supports to be
successful we would hope that those
teams would be having that discussion
and would be looking at that there are
some students who if you took them away
they've made enough gains they've kind
of closed those gaps that you could take
the services away there are other
students that you really need to look at
that and say they still would not be
successful if we took those services
away so that should be a discussion that
each iep team is
having when they meet on the student
would would um
[Music]
would that be something that a parent
could come to you if the school decided
one thing and they were seeing something
different so natasha um loop as i said
lupiani takes all the complaints but she
also answers just because i don't have
time
um she also answers a lot of parent
questions so she will um walk parents
through the process she will talk to you
about the different options you have
she may she'll provide you to some
resources that might be available she's
only one person and but she does you
know she does answer that if it's
something that she's unclear of
sometimes she'll pass it on to another
member of my team so we may pass it on
to somebody who has more experience in
an area than she does or she consults
with us repeatedly to try to get that
answer correct to make sure that we're
providing information to the parent
thank you thank you very much
with that we're gonna represent a ford
has anyone ever been prosecuted for
denial of services to a child
there have been due process hearings
where children were not receiving
services and and the district was
ordered to
provide the services or provide
compensatory services yes
thank you
not seeing any further questions thank
you very much
and this will close the hearing on 381
we are going to take a five minute break
for everybody to stand up stretch
and we'll come back and start this
upright again in about five minutes with
the next bill which is
who knows 3.94 happened together
that
it just i've heard
thank you
okay yeah right
okay we're about ready to get going here
everybody try to find your seats
okay
okay uh we're ready to open up this
hearing on senate bill 394
and i'd like to welcome senator jay kahn
to our meeting present the bill
thank you mr chairman uh and members of
the
house education commission
committee
i'm jay kahn
from keene
state senator for 15 of 23 towns in
cheshire county
i'm here today to present senate bill
which deals with our definition of a
child with disabilities under special
education law
the bill that is
394 is very similar to a house bill that
you considered earlier in the year house
bill 1513
which we have in the senate education
committee
and are considering
we had a hearing on that bill this last
week so it's kind of fresh in my mind
the wording between the two bills is
almost identical
so
where
house education ended up and where
senate education ended up is is very
much in the same place so let me explain
that place
we
currently have special education
services to provide it to students
between the ages of 3
and 21.
so that services
cut off at 21 years
of age
when this has been debated in the
legislature over the past few years and
mr chairman you probably recall this a
couple of years ago
but the testimony around it was
parents wanting
their student
to be able to complete a school year
once they reached 21.
so that when there wasn't a cliff
that in fact an iep
uh individualized education plan for a
student when they reached 21 wouldn't
just end on their 21st birthday but in
fact that student could continue to the
end of that school year
that
and that's what you did in house bill
and that's what we did in the senate in
house bill 394 which is before you today
uh is explain
that change that has a fairly minimal
fiscal impact
on
our schools public schools in the state
and the reason why is because
most of the school districts in the
state
are already doing that
it makes good sense to do that
when a student
is going through that kind of service
the goal
uh of
uh
the idea
whenever the handoff is to developmental
services
state developmental services
the goal is that a student
to ensure equality of opportunity
full participation independent living
and economic self-sufficiency for
individuals with disabilities so that's
why
it's important to complete the plan
and to provide
as much of a
transition
to those
goals which are the idea goals
all right
so
uh
that's that's the good part i think
that's the easy part for us
the more difficult part that you're
going to hear that i've been hearing uh
in through our
senate
hearings
is that
other states
have gone to
court in the last year
let me let me lay out the landscape in
this in the nation there are eight other
states that were at the beginning of
this year at the same place that new
hampshire is
2 21.
there are 13 other states
that have language that we are intending
to go to
which is
221 through the school year in which
they turn
but there is a recent
decision in rhode island
versus kl and it was decided in the
federal district court
that they needed to provide services
through
through 21.
that's a cost that we don't know i i
don't maybe somebody can put numbers on
it
but it's not only what the cost is in
total it's how would it be parsed out
right
so here are some of the guiding statutes
that we need to try to bring into this
one is
uh 189 1 which is uh
what we are amending here which says
that
uh we i'm sorry
186 c2 is what we're amending that's the
definition of a child with disabilities
in 189 1a
we described that our duty to provide
public education
is
until a student has acquired a high
school diploma or has reached age 21.
age 21.
i don't know what the other states that
have gone through this litigation
process had as their language
but our our requirement is consistent
right
school age is 2
age 21.
special education age is
221.
so at the current time we're consistent
but the courts have
said that
if you provide other educational
services like adult education
you need to go through 21
which is the federal definition if you
don't have state let
language
if i've complicated this enough
good because it's
it
it it got more complicated through this
session
i think as we learn more about the court
decisions
and so the question is how do what do we
do next
with this
i think the fact that two education
committees studying this question
arrived at the same place
is a good starting point we need to get
to through the school year when a
student turns 21
but we can't miss
the question that the department of
education is raising
about
how do we prepare ourselves
for the fact that we're likely going to
wind up
at through 21
at some point down the road
so what i'd like to do mr chairman is uh
work with you
uh and maybe somebody else who was
involved in
your decision
uh here
to propose a alongside
the through the school year as we have
it in this bill an amendment that would
bring it to
a study
commission that we create a study
commission
alongside this bill
that would
involve stakeholders and determine how
we need to modify 186 c18
which is how we reimburse special
education services
because
these are not going to be simple
special education services
for students who have not completed a
high school diploma at age 21.
these will be more complex
these will reach
the
thresholds that we've got in special
education funding
so school districts
are not going to cover the costs with
two thousand dollars of additional
adequate education aid
they're likely going to be covering the
costs
up to three and a half times
their average cost of instruction like
seventy thousand dollars
covering all those costs
and
they'll be covering twenty percent of
everything above that until ten times
which gets us into
the hundred
plus
uh
thousand dollars uh potentially
per student and uh
and and we so we need we need to walk
through this
i think in in some
studied manner uh in the coming year
with the department of education
uh providing advice and school districts
telling us
are they going to be how are they going
to be able to accommodate this and be
able to prepare for this
in their school budgets
this bill already has an implementation
date of 2324 school year
so
with the study commission
running through that
23-24 school year
we ought to be able to have some better
information for the legislature
to to be prepared to act uh in a second
step
uh down the road so that that's uh
hopefully i've laid that out and i'm
glad to answer any questions mr chairman
well senator thank you very much and it
just already the figures are going
through my head here are we talking
roughly around five million dollars per
year
it could be that and it could be north
of that yeah
yes and and how that gets parsed out
between the school
school aid formulas and
the at the categorical aid that we've
got for special education
uh
would needs to be considered thank you
are there questions from the committee
representative
sure thanks very much mr chair and thank
you very much senator khan for bringing
this in and also for um for uh adding
that level of complexity to um to what
what we thought was uh was a more
straightforward issue but um but i
really appreciate you actually bringing
up the language from 189
um one a
and i i went and took a look at it and
um and if that were to be amended to
to has reached the age 22. would that
basically also be saying that that any
student
would have a right to to attend their
public school until they reach the age
of 22. it would any student any student
thank you
let's try the condom and and and just to
to reflect on and what might be the
complication there
22 year old students in school with
students who are 17
can pose
some
you know challenges to manage the
different age groups and their
you know
what they are entitled to do which is
it might be substances
yes go ahead
yeah and thank you very much senator um
and and when we're talking about all
students i'm not just talking about
special education students i'm talking
about students that might choose a i
mean most students choose to
complete their high school
you know requirements and graduate with
their class when they're 17 or 18 years
old but should a student want to take
maybe more electives or
or other classes that don't necessarily
tack on credits that lead to graduation
um
they could they could extend that out
through uh through age um
21 under current law and um and 22.
is that correct well 21
under currently right and and and or
until they graduated so
many students are completing
all the credits they need for graduation
by the time that they reach
17 or 18. i mean the goal is for
students to complete a high school
education not to continue to
i mean i don't want to go too far down
that
path but i
that's what i take is our as our primary
goal is to help students complete a
high school
competencies and qualify for graduation
from a public high school
not necessarily to provide adult
continuing education which school
districts can continue to to provide
right and the and the the charter career
academy
is sort of leveraging that um
by delaying the high school diploma
until until
a student has taken two years of
community college
i unders i i i
understand the proposal that there is
for that kind of
program right thank you
we don't want to go down that
road yeah i i understand reps and lekkas
thank you
i have two questions one uh totally
unrelated to each other
one of them is what does
a person do now once they reach 21
and they still need they can't support
themselves and all of that who pays
for their continuing care etc as it is
now
thanks for that question so it once a
student ages out of the
the services provided through public
education
uh uh
adult developmental services
the
regional offices will provide
adult services through health and human
services the regional offices for
developmental disabilities
and
uh and that's that's the transition
thank you and then
yeah the other one is um
would a student be required to stay in
until the end of the year let's say they
turned 21 and they were looking forward
to
being done with school even though
they could use more schooling
who makes that decision at that point
thanks
good clarification uh
a student can
doesn't need to graduate from high
school
and that happens we know that happens uh
whether you've got developmental
disabilities or not
and
so
there's no requirement to stay in school
and in fact uh
some
students
and their families will decide
that it's not in the best interest of
the child to continue to receive
educational services that in fact a
different kind of transition should
happen
and
developmental services will uh
uh
provide some assistance
below 21 years and and that is that is a
i mean that transition handoff is always
of concern to the families
whoops thank you are there further
questions for representative woodcock
thank you chairman it's not calling good
morning
i just want to be clear on your
uh amendment dialogue
are you asking us
not to move forward with with 394
or uh as it's presented or you're asking
us to move forward with 394 and in
addition attach an amendment to it
uh the latter
okay thank you thank you chairman
welcome
further questions
thank you very much senator thank you
i'm going to take the liberty here
rather than going with uh the next
elected
official here representative cordelli
i'm going to ask chris bond from the
attorney general's office come on up
welcome
thank you representative ladd thank you
um so for the record my name is chris
bond i'm actually counsel to the
department of education and the state
board of education but i also serve in a
dual capacity where i am affiliated with
the attorney general's office and i'm
actually here
um on behalf of attorney of attorney
general formella today to testify as to
the
the potential legal challenges that uh
not having the special ed services run
through age 22 or through age 21
inclusive i.e up until the 22nd birthday
may pose
so um i think senator khan did a nice
job sort of explaining um just to
elaborate a little further the case at
issue um just for the record
is um
kl
versus rhode island board of education
and the citation is 907 f third 639
so it i just want to clarify it is a
first circuit court of appeals case so
in the district court in rhode island
actually um found in favor of rhode
island and found that it was okay to not
provide the services up to age 22
but the first circuit reversed that on a
2-1 decision that's the decision here
that is as it's the first circuit court
of appeals that is binding precedent on
new hampshire so new hampshire is bound
to follow
this case law and
that's the reason
why we believe it would be a significant
challenge for us to defend a law
that and there would be a significant
risk that the law would be held to be
incompatible with the idea
if it were challenged and just to go
through sort of the logic of the case
the idea provides
that
states are required to provide a free
and appropriate public education to all
children with disabilities residing in
the state between the ages of 3 and 21
inclusive and that 3 in 21 inclusive
language has been held to mean
um
until the the child turns 22.
now there's an exception to that at 20
usc 1412
a1b1
which says that the obligation to
provide a free and appropriate public
education to those children um
does not apply with respect to children
aged 18 through 21 in a state to the
extent that its application to those
children would be inconsistent with
state law or practice and so new
hampshire and many other states had
relied on that exception to not provide
the services up until the 22nd birthday
but what the court found in this case
was that because rhode island
had public dollars that supported adult
education programs beyond age 21 that
they could not avail themselves of that
exception um so specifically
the factors that the court says they the
first circuit will look at is whether
there's a significant level of state or
local government funding for adult
education whether there's public
administration or oversight of that
educational process and whether that
process is designed to bring students up
to the level they would be at if they
completed high school and they found
those present here and then found that
that exception didn't apply so there's a
significant risk that if they looked at
new hampshire's program
um
they might make the similar conclusion
which is why we felt it important the
committee understand that that's the
substantial risk if they don't move that
age up to 22.
and i'm happy to take any questions
okay are there any questions from the
committee representative waltz
attorney waltz
thank you so are you familiar with house
bill 1513
yes okay so what i'm hearing you say is
that
house bill 1513 is consistent with
federal language
but that
senate bill
394 if we were to change it from 21 to
22 is consistent with the requirements
of the first circuit
um
so that because looking at 1513 that's
exactly what i'm hearing the languages
in federal law but that we would have to
provide services through 22
um so i think until the 22nd birthday i
may have misspoke through 21 inclusive
is the requirement
up until the 22nd
i apologize if i wasn't clear well it
was probably me not picking up the
nuance okay but but again 15 the the
house bill is the one that's consistent
with federal law so if we adopt that
then we're going to be consistent with
the first circuit decision then it just
becomes what our practices are
i'm sorry
it's not consistent with the first
circuit
all right my confusion
okay i i i am familiar with the bill i
had seen versions where it went up to
the 22nd birthday and amendments where
it didn't i don't know where that bill
currently sits but if it does it to be
consistent with the holding
um in kl
it would have to go through the 22nd
birthday but i also want to make clear
that um
i'm just highlighting the significant
risk the state faces that
there could be an argument that the
adult education program in new hampshire
is signific is significantly different
from rhode island in such a way that is
meaningful
we haven't done the research to know
that that would be probably a pretty uh
um
discovery intensive process to figure
out
what it was but the the state uh it is
clear from this decision that rhode
island wasn't funding all of adult
education um and they had some
administrative oversight and those were
found to be sufficient so i think that
just tightens the risk but um
i just want to be careful that i'm not
um so it sounds to me like the the
the bill that would have the least
exposure for the state is to simply say
we're going to provide special ed
services through a 22nd birthday
yes that's my understanding
and i should also add i meant to add um
we are aware of one advocacy group that
we believe is preparing a lawsuit
against the state um but they're waiting
to see the outcome of this legislation
and then i became aware of another
parent who is preparing a due process
claim against their uh
school so um it's not just the risk that
the state will be sued but there's the
risk that um individual districts will
be sued too on the basis of this and we
are aware of at least one due process
claim that was brought against the
school district on the basis of the kl
case that case was settled so i don't
know what the results of that were i
wasn't privy to the settlement but um uh
my assumption is that the parent got the
services that they were requesting
because it was a pretty quick settlement
after the filing
representative moffat do you have a
question okay
thank you mr and thanks for taking my
question you just mentioned a parent
bringing a suit so given the age of
majority being what it is
my question is
what about the
i hate to say child or the word child
has been used over and over
with regard to this legislation i'm a
co-sponsor 15 13.
but um
what if the
the student uh is at odds with the
parent on
you know if they're a special education
student do they surrender their their
sovereignty what if the student and the
parent don't agree on the course of
action for a 20 year old or whatever
sure that's a great question um first of
all i want to correct my statement i
said the parent i actually don't know if
it was a parent i should have said a
student i don't know if it was a parent
who brought it on behalf of the student
or the student who brought in their own
capacity um
i i believe that would be my
understanding is that would be on a
case-by-case basis you could have a
child who had some sort of a court
finding that past the age of majority
they still had some sort of a guardian
who could be the parent but in other
cases um just because someone's an ie
and on an iep certainly doesn't mean
that they're not competent to make those
decisions so there could be
either situation you could have
students that could make those decisions
themselves whether to stay in school for
example as senator khan noted there's no
requirement to graduate from high school
so a student who's eligible for these
services doesn't necessarily have to
participate whether that's their
decision or the parents would depend on
the individual circumstances and who had
been adjudicated to be uh competent to
make decisions for that child that's my
understanding
sure okay thanks
thank you uh represent luna thank you
very much mr chair and um and and thank
you attorney bond for uh for joining us
um this morning so would um
would would school districts if they
wanted to under current law be able to
um
provide education through 21 inclusives
include inclusive today
yes my understanding is that they can
although under the current statutes they
wouldn't receive any reimbursement from
the state for special education services
beyond age 21. okay and a follow-up on
that yeah would they would they receive
the adequacy grant from the uh from the
state for those students
i am not certain i would have to look at
that and get back to you um my my
assumption would be no but i don't i
don't know for certain yeah no thank
thanks and i i think that would be uh
obviously i think all this is sort of
funneling into what senator khan is
proposing and really understanding this
but yeah i was i was
interested in what the definition of
adma
currently used in law and just so
we all happen to have heard a bill last
week on adma so i was looking at the
definition of that and it's not clear to
me either
sure i haven't looked at it recently so
no thank you
representative porter
thank you mr chair and you might not
know the answer to this question but the
reason why these bills were brought
forth was because
parents were concerned about losing
services mid-year for their child
what do they do in another state i mean
if we bring it to 22 and you turn 22 in
may
or june or march or you're going to end
it'll be the same problem just moved up
a year so there is no solution you're
saying you think to this problem
other than spending
getting into the rabbit hole that
representative senator khan said
well um
thank you for the question um first of
all i i want to make clear i'm not here
to uh to weigh in on any policy matters
and so i certainly understand that's an
important consideration
um
i would say there's nothing i see in the
kl decision that would prevent
legislation that would say
you can complete the school year or the
semester
once you
achieve age 22 but if you're going to
try to cut it off before 22 that's when
you run into the kl decisions so um
you know
the merits of cutting off mid-year or
not i understand that so um you know
there are so rhode island has made this
change because they were the direct
subject of the lawsuit
maine upon seeing the decision and
they're also in the first circuit with
us so this is binding precedent on them
they have made the decision to go
through age
through the 22nd birthday not through
age 22. through the 22nd birthday i um
i don't know whether that continues
beyond that to encompass more of a
school year it could but that would be
sort of a policy discretion area so
yep
thank you are there further questions
from the committee yes representative
cornell thank you thank you so if their
birthday is in november and they turn 22
in november
so we're just kind of perpetuating what
we're trying to do away within they
could say okay you're 22 it's november
you're not going to finish the school
year that
yeah so i think if i'm understanding the
question correctly um
yes um the what the what the idea
requires according to kl is that in a
state where there is public support for
education as defined by the kl court and
i don't want to get too specific about
that because that would be the subject
potentially of a lawsuit but in that
circumstance
the special education services need to
be provided up until the 22nd birthday
so you could have a cliff
scenario where november 15th is the
birthday and that's the last day and
they they were in class on the 14th and
they're not there on the 16th you could
do that i can understand why for policy
reasons that might not be palatable
there's nothing that would prevent you
from letting them finish out that school
year but if you try to do it on the
other end and you try to say well once
they reach their 21st birthday we'll let
them finish then you've got a problem
because if they're still 21 when the
next school year starts under this
potential whole application of this
holding there'd still be a problem so
you do have that flexibility but only
when you're over the sort of limit
that's set by kl not not before
thank you are there further questions
from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you thank you very much thank you
representative cordelli
uh thank you mr chairman and uh fellow
committee members uh for the record
glenn cordelli representing tuftonboro
moultonborough and sandwich in the
beautiful lakes region
you've heard quite a bit of testimony
about
age 21 inclusive rhode island maine and
so forth and and the need for us
probably to do something
we did have
hb 1513
which passed the house and was sent to
the senate um
i attended the hearing on that in the
senate and
i got the impression that the senate
might look to uh amend uh that bill
um based on some of the similar
testimony that uh you just heard
um
my amendment that is making its way
around
um
the committee
uh basically says
um
that
it's not just 21 inclusive but if they
turn
22 on
thursday
they can finish out the semester they're
not kicked out of school
the day after their 22nd birthday
um i i don't think that that's
um
reasonable
um as a policy for the state
um
i had done some research trying to find
out what other states how other states
approach it
the only thing that i could find in a
chart a global
state by state comparison
actually dated back to
2004 with a document from the us
department of education um so it's a
little bit old a little bit dated but
even back then it was all over the place
in terms of um
what states did in this regard
and there were certainly states that
said um
up until their 22nd birthday
and i've talked to a
an education advocate here in new
hampshire who thinks
they should
leave school on you know right after
their 22nd birthday
um
but i i'm taking the approach and this
amendment uh for your consideration
um that
they would finish out the semester
during which they turn 22.
um
i i think that's more reasonable
approach
for us as a policy and also
for the student and their family
and i thank you very much for your
attention thank you are there any
questions for representative cordelli
representative baum and then
representative i think tanner had her
hand up
do you know
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative cadelli uh
do you know that if all high schools in
the state
run on a semester program
i i'm not sure
so those that don't would mean to the
end of the year rather the end of the
semester
represent tanner
thank you for taking my question very
similar question
you know our school year the school year
that i worked under was divided into
four quarters
um
and i'm just wondering if semester is
defined anywhere
in statute or whether we need to have a
better
definition
we certainly could
play with the
terminology of semester certainly
for the further questions representative
luno
sure thanks very much mr chair how would
this work for students with efa accounts
um
uh i
uh
let's see
i'll
those programs um should follow um the
law in terms of uh uh the definition of
a child with a disability
so follow-up yes so so we've
we've already concluded that that under
current law and under
um uh whatever uh language comes out of
that that the the age um whether it's
until they turn 21 or until
22 they turned 22 that that a student
would be entitled to
to essentially attend school
and um and and potentially um
uh
and and and have that school receive
the adequate education grant and i
believe the adequate education grant um
formula is what the efa program uh
follows as well correct so i guess
very straightforward would a would a
student who's who's uh who has an efa
and being homeschooled
any student
who has an efa and is being homeschooled
um and potentially going to private
school be able to receive that efa grant
from the from the state until um until
the end
on your on your amendment here until the
end of the semester in which they turn
22 years old
uh thank you just thinking about it as i
think back
on the legislation for the education
freedom accounts i think it says 3 to 18
but i would have to go back and look at
the version that was actually signed
into law
are there further questions
thank you very much
got three more cards here
uh jane bergeron
good afternoon for the record my name is
jane bergeron and i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire
association of special ed administrators
and thank you for the opportunity to
testify
i will keep my uh comments brief
our association certainly recognizes the
importance of providing services to
students with disabilities
through age 21 or
different scenarios that we've discussed
today some of the things that we would
like to bring to your attention
is based on on the fiscal impact and
making sure that our policy makers
fully understand the implications
upon our taxpayers
you will note that
the fiscal note with the bill is focused
on and dedicated to
children and youth who are placed in
residential settings and those who are
placed in alternative school settings
we know that this bill will impact
a good number of kids with disabilities
in our public schools
and those numbers are not included or
considered
in the bill so when you think about your
kids
who have transition planning or younger
adults they tend to be
young adults who have quite a bit of
services and support
so many of them are out in the community
they require specialized transportation
they're required job coaches some have
one-to-one nurses some have behavioral
specialists with them many of these
services are contracted out to vendors
to provide these services out in the
community
and so as you think about
a bill like this do consider
the numbers of kids who are currently in
our public schools not in residential
schools or in alternative settings
because that
certainly will have an impact on
our community our our taxpayers and we
just want to make sure folks are taking
that into consideration
so i would open it up for uh questions
also you heard today
comments about letting kids stay through
the end of the school year defining what
school year is many of our children and
youth have extended school year programs
does that is that included in that so
not only defining semester but defining
the school year i think would also be
important for us to be thinking about
thank you very much i've got a question
for you in terms of medicaid
we have a number of our
special ed students which are medicaid
qualifying
and we get reimbursement from medicaid
for those services
um would this continue
to the age that we're talking about here
you know i i don't have the answer for
that but i could get it for you
or yeah or maybe becky would know thank
you for that
where's our attorney back there
okay um
katelyn do you have any idea on that
okay well thank you are there other
questions
reverend woodcock thank you chairman
uh good morning once again or good
afternoon actually um just a quick
question
you talked before 17 18 percent or
rather than what i did the number we
generally assume for new hampshire
youngsters that are involved in special
ed services
do you have a breakdown of a
guesstimation if you will of the numbers
that actually are in the 18 to 21 range
of that percentage
i don't have that information but we can
get it for you becky might know off
that from them yeah that'd be terrific
if you could thank you representative
thank you for the question i'm very
welcome represent hobson
you have a question no
okay
further questions
thank you very much jane thank you uh
the next person is more
umura ryan
thank you
chairman lad
and commission
um i supported hb 1513 as it was um
written i know it was amended to what sb
394 is now
um and as the federal language is age 21
inclusive i believe research support age
21 inclusive i would also support going
beyond that as i had said in the 394
hearing in the senate the state of
minnesota goes up to age 26.
um
every child should be given every
opportunity and this is from the federal
government the usda to complete a
full-blown high school diploma because
that leads it basically leads to a path
for a better education the federal
district court that they're talking
about in the rhode island case is the
one that governs our area because we are
district one
and if a kid with disabilities gets
told they have to leave school with a
high school diploma i don't see why a
normal student wouldn't be told the same
um
the the child or guardian can choose to
leave school at any time that is the way
it works um we've actually had
situations where
a parent has not filed for guardianship
yet their kid turned 18 and the school
came to the kid and said you don't
really want to come to school you're not
interested why don't you just sign up
kid signs out it's not reversible
it's not reversible
um so we often tell parents get the
guardianship as soon as possible
um and be very specific about education
services
adult services is not
anything to really ascribe to because
once the student is done with school and
michelle mckeon just wrote an article
about this where she said keep your kid
in school as long as possible because
adult services has no goals
it has no interaction with other people
other than maybe going to the mall or
going to the supermarket
and it has no way of pushing you further
towards an independent living or
employment my son in particular has been
registered with vocational rehab since
the age of 14
and thus far he has not completed a
single internship rotation
so
um
i believe
attorney bond also quoted in the 1513
hearing that 40 states went to age 21
inclusive which is 22nd birthday so i'm
here to say that we will support age 21
inclusive we will support beyond age 21
inclusive but we will not accept less
because we know the federal government
guaranteed us more
so we're here to support age 21
inclusive or more
and and also on the adequacy funding the
doa had informed me that the adequacy
funding is based off attendance on
october 1st so if the student is in
attendance on october 1st the school
retains the funding for that year
regardless of whether the student moves
out of the district or anything like
that
thank you
any questions
nancy thank you very much
we're at the end of our pink card we do
have a technical assistance as needed
from rebecca fradette
rebecca
i think
attorney fenton had gotten some
questions that she forwarded on to me
regarding numbers
um so currently we have four students
who are age 21
in school right now
and they will all be
exiting at the end of the school year
we did have 20 students who started the
school year at age 21 at age 20 and when
they turned 21 they were exited um at or
before their birthday
so there's only four left that are
beyond 21. we currently have 186
students who are age 20
and they um but
unless i go through each individual
student i don't know who is going to
continue on until past their 21st
birthday but there are 186 students
um
so the question was how many students
will this bill include if we use the 21
inclusive language so theoretically it
could include those 186 students
um until their 22nd birthday if this if
this is the case the cost at minimum
what we figure is a cost per pupil when
we do special education aid we work with
caitlin davis's office to determine that
number currently the cost per pupil is
17985.66
so if every single student were to
continue 180 stick six students and
we're going to send you this diana has
it to send to you um it would be right
around 3.3 million dollars at just the
cost per pupil if every one of those
students went to the 3.5 times the cost
per pupil that we provided for special
education aid it would be about 11
million so those were numbers that were
asked of me
um
currently the way the law is written if
anyone stays beyond 21 and if we even if
you changed it to 22 we would not
provide any special education aid or
idea funding to those students because
our state law would say up to 21.
we do not provide it to students right
now if they turn 21 and they stay in
school for the remainder of that year
because our law does say up to 21
and then so but if they did stay it
would be the same cost as i had listed
for those other students but those were
questions that had been presented to me
from somewhere here
okay are there any questions represented
walls
so if we change this law if we change
this law to say that we're going to
provide education through 22nd birthday
does that mean the funding will then
follow from the state yep so if you
change the law i would be able to
provide funding up until their 22nd
birthday um and then if they went beyond
their 22nd birthday i would not be able
to provide special education aid or idea
funding
follow-up yes if we change the law to
say this the end of the school year of
their 22nd birthday would you be able to
fund the full school year yes i would
so whatever change we make here is going
to be determining of your funding yes
thank you
further questions
so that closes uh that's the last card
unless there's somebody else in the
audience to speak on this bill and so we
will close
394.
yeah hold on
let's see what useful
how many cards do we have here for 420
two
oh gee i didn't know
whoops
sorry
okay
center waters
i know what
no we we'll we'd have to take it in the
order i guess
mr chairman i i may have to believe
so what we could do is we could have 4
20 introduced then we can recess it to
follow 421
and uh 421
grant
can you come forward and please
introduce 420 and then we'll recess it
immediately absolutely and then you can
let senator hennessey know what we did
i will be very brief but the department
of education here is to back me up when
you get back to 420.
good morning chairman lad members of the
committee my name is grant bosse from
the new hampshire senate here to
introduce senate bill 420 on behalf of
senator aaron hennessey its prime
sponsor
this bill establishes an ongoing
extraordinary need education funding
grant this bill will allow additional
funding to go to the neediest of our
schools through the state
based on the town's property equalized
valuation per pupil
eligible to receive free and reduced
lunch so let me just go through that
formula again you calculate the property
equalized valuation for each town you
then divide it by the number of pupils
eligible for free and reduced lunch
if that number is
less than a million dollars you receive
the full amount of the grant you then
get a sliding scale down
if it's more than six million dollars
per free and reduced lunch pupil you do
not receive a grant
this extraordinary need grant is set up
as an ongoing grant in addition to the
adequacy aid and the ongoing 35 million
dollars in relief aid
we added in the budget last year this
bill would send additional funding to
towns on top of what was accomplished in
the budget an additional 14.7 million
dollars for school year 2023
these grants are intended to provide
consistency and stability for school
districts therefore they will not be
limited to one-time use towns qualifying
for this extraordinary need grant can be
found in the fiscal note at the end of
the bill i would defer questions to the
department of education but if you have
a question for senator hennessy i'll
make sure she gets you an answer thank
you and we ask for your support for
senate bill 420. thank you very much
we will
recess this particular hearing right now
and
come back to it following 421
at time to be announced
welcome senator waters
uh thank you so much mr chairman so
we're on to 421. i'm senator david
waters uh district 4 introducing senate
bill
421 relative to dual concurrent
enrollment for career and technical
education center students and if i may
say as an aside i had
signed in in support of 420 as well i
wanted you all to know there's
bipartisan support coming out of the
senate for that bill
but um 421
um deals with our existing dual and
concurrent enrollment program under
rsa 188 a highly effective and strongly
supported program that lets high school
students take a couple of classes
under doing concurrent enrollment save a
lot of money and give them a leg up on
their career when they go on to
community college or other higher
education the bill makes a couple of
changes um the funding the fund for this
bill
was transferred to
uh over to the community college system
and so they're administratoring it now
and under their current
practices uh they
release funding at the time of student
enrollment which is what we do
for adequacy grants right so it's kind
of the same thing as as that
there had been some concern from the
commissioner of education that well if
they if you got the money
you know what will you really do to make
sure the student stays enrolled and
completes the course and so on
and you know i i get that you know and i
talked with commissioner aw
about it and um
you know it was also assured by
community college assistant new
hampshire they do they do a lot and the
high schools the high schools
particularly do a lot because that's
where the courses are taught to make
sure the students are are completing the
courses but but nonetheless we thought
then down at the bottom of the bill a
new in uh paragraph
enrollment that this is language the
commissioner thought would be a good way
to deal with his concerns about when the
funds are going out so it says there's
going to be an annual report
on student enrollment successful
completion grades of students and doing
concurrent enrollment courses
and
that would be important to have to see
if there is an issue around whether
students are completing or at a
different rate that they might have um
otherwise
now the other part of this bill uh mr
chairman really kind of is in tandem to
what uh we did in house bill 1661. it's
just you know these two bills came to
came out of um
the study committee and our ongoing work
on
on ctes i must say i'm a little jealous
that house bill 61 got a 35 million
dollar parking garage
so i want something on this too all
right
well we can put anything you want on it
anyhow but maybe the uh maybe this maybe
the cte
mobile
mobile vehicle can park at the new
garage okay so it'll be good um but the
the basic principle here is that we want
and you you and i share this value mr
chairman others on the committee we
believe that career and technical
education is fundamentally kind of a
right for students in our
our state and we want to make sure that
every eligible student
uh can
enroll in career and technical education
no matter where they may be because this
is our future work source for us it's
opportunity for students and their
aspirations
there we had wanted to make sure that
students who are not public school
students
had the opportunity to take queer
technical education
there has been an interpretation that
because of the way the
bill the the law is referenced that
those students who are in non-public
schools um could not take advantage of
career and technical education and i
personally you know with education
freedom savings account you know we're
going to have more students who are
taking that option and going to
you know private schools and i i want
them the private schools are going to be
offering the cte programs but we can and
we ought to make sure they can take
those classes as well so that's why you
see it here the governing body
institution is in the case of non-public
schools shall develop and adopt a policy
permitting students residing in a
district or attendance of the nonpublic
school from grades 10 11 12 to
participate in dual concurrent
enrollment programs so just that
reference there the governing body not
the school board we'll open it up so
that the the
the students who are in those other
other schools are now going to be
eligible to be in the doing concur
enrollment program so i think it's
pretty simple mr chairman but um there
it is and i know that we have both beth
doran and shannon reed here
uh to to tag team on on
how this you know what the program is if
you have more questions about that and
and how this benefits uh the students
thank you very much senator waters and
before i open up to the committee i do
have one question
and the question is dealing with line 14
of the bill
where it says or in attendance at the
non-public school
we have a number of non-public schools
such as
kua holderness school
where the students are not residents of
the state
so should it read
or is a resident and in attendance at
the non-public school
well um i see what you're getting at uh
i think that that's best answered by
beth or
or shannon
i mean this this wording is a little
tricky and i i don't want to
get ahead of myself
i will ask that question representative
porter
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
waters um oh excuse me if i if i just
say one of the problems um
representative
is that
i think that the or in attendance
um
you know if it's a student who's
taking the education freedom
savings account and they're not you know
they're going to another
what is the school happens to be outside
the district i mean anyways i'll let
them talk about it but i just want to
make sure we're being
inclusive um so that
excuse me i'm sorry
it's fine i know how mines work um or
don't work
maybe
you said that senator i didn't say that
um
can the
state tell a non-public school or
private school that they have to do
something
no but
it can certainly tell them it's a great
opportunity for their students
but the bill says that shall develop and
adopt a policy permitting students
to be dual and concurrent
well i'm sorry i misanswered that i i i
think that um
you know if we're offering this and and
schools want to take advantage of it
they ought to have a policy
for that opportunity
so
yeah are there further questions of
senator waters
thank you for hanging loose along with
us well i appreciate your indulgence mr
chairman thank you i will you know
obviously i'd be available for questions
that may come up later in the hearing
but thank you again thanks
okay um
go back to the pink cards here beth were
you wanting to speak today too or or
shannon together both of you
there are the cards over there
you're both representing
community college system we are thank
you for having us i i guess i should say
good afternoon i think my testimony was
probably written as good morning um
thank you for the opportunity to come
and talk about uh senate bill 421 i want
to provide just a very brief bit of
background on these programs
a number of years ago the community
college system created dual and
concurrent enrollment programs in new
hampshire um the largest of which is
called the running start program
which is a program where high school
students take courses at their high
school during their school day
excuse me taught by their high school
teachers who are who are acting really
in partnership with the college faculty
member to teach that course and the
student gets high school credit and the
student gets college credit for that
course
it's a very successful program it
enrolls about 8 000 students every year
who take one or more of these dual
credit courses gives students a real um
well running start on their college
education in a way that is accessible to
them and affordable
and it covers a real range of
disciplines
in addition to running start we also
offer a program called early college
which is similar in that it it confers
both high school and college credit but
but in early college students will
actually go to the college campus and
take a course so there's a sort of a
nuance
difference between those two
um
and then there's also east art which is
similar but the courses are taken online
in partnership with the virtual
vlax virtual learning academy so those
are the three different kinds of dual
and concurrent enrollment programs
offered through the community colleges
here in new hampshire
about four years ago
a um
a scholarship fund was created it was
established and created
um
to support
dual and concurrent enrollment in stem
and stem-related
uh courses
and this is a subject actually of 421
not the courses writ large but this
funding opportunity for stem and stem
related courses
and then two years ago
cte courses was were added to that um
grouping of courses that could be
supported through the scholarship
funding so initially in this program the
funding ran through the department of
education
and at the end of every semester the
community colleges would inform the doe
uh the number of students who
participated and the doe would
essentially remit
the funding to the community college
system
to cover their the cost of their
enrollment
in the last um budget the department
came in and indicated that it was no
longer
able to
to fill that role
and they had left the program out of
their budget um citing you know
administrative
burdens of the program
the house finance committee really
wanting this program to move forward um
and represent vlad
was involved in that effort as well
asked the community colleges if we would
then administer the program so we it
could remain an opportunity for new
hampshire students we said we would
so we have been
administering the program since then so
the funding then comes directly to the
community college and we essentially
account for it based on student
participation at the end of a given
semester
does that more or less make sense okay
so if senate bill 421 really relates to
the the funding program for those stem
stem related and cte courses
and as senator waters noted it makes two
um tweaks really to the program which we
see as serving the interests of fairness
and process improvement
so the first change is really the
process improvement um change and that
is that
the payment would be triggered upon the
student
starting the course not upon successful
completion of the course that aligns
with payment practices generally for our
colleges and i think probably most most
educational organizations and it
streamlines the administration for us
because we we can do that at the
beginning and don't have to kind of um
catch up at the end with where you may
have
a variety of different outcomes
and then the second
excuse me the second change
just adds
the
those non-public schools
that currently have a running start in
them for example but
for purpose of this funding program
don't really fit within the language of
the program
as it is currently written so
right now for a school
to have its students eligible for the
funding
the school or the school board or the
school district needs to
enter into an agreement with the
community colleges and that basically
just outlines how this all works
but because the language of the program
says the school board of each school
district
then that pr that really leaves out
schools like
uh trinity high school in manchester
bishop brady here in concord schools
that are very much part of the ecosystem
of new hampshire's communities and where
students go but are just left out of the
language of this of this bill um i mean
of the current program
so that is what the what the bill does
the the senate amended it to add the
annual report which we think is
certainly a reasonable request um so
that we report we will report student
performance metrics on an annual basis
to the department of education
um
so that that's essentially the outline
and this is really in the context of a
program running start that's been around
for
just about 20 years has steadily evolved
in all that time and really grown very
very well and very effectively for new
hampshire students and families
and we
we um we'll be happy to answer any
questions that you have about the the
bill or the program and before i turn it
over for questions though i'd like to
just ask my colleague beth doran who
runs this program and runs our college
access programs generally if i've left
anything out that you'd like to add or
or clarify
no you you have not left anything
anything out that's very comprehensive
thank you uh represent tanner
thank you for taking my question if my
memory serves me correct uh in order for
this for the uh
college course to be taught at the high
school level the teacher has to have
certain requirements
and i'm wondering um how that's
how that's going to work in in some of
these non-public schools like perhaps
prenda or
kai which are micro schools that don't
have certified teachers or
um in any
will
how are they held to the same standard
they they would need to be held to the
same standard mostly because we in order
to maintain the integrity of the program
the high school teachers need to have
the same requirements as our adjunct
faculty so that's an area where we
really try to stick with exactly what is
required
of any collet anybody teaching a college
course within the community college
system
i might add that that's one of the
reasons why we put in the national
alliance for concurrent enrollment
program that is a program which
addresses
all those issues that you're thinking of
so the standards are high
they must be the same as offered by the
university itself or the community
college system itself exactly yeah with
their accreditation process
represent woodcock
thank you chairman lad you may know the
answer i have forgotten i'm sure they
know the answer uh home school
youngsters
how how do they participate in this
program
they would not necessarily participate
in running start unless they're
attending the the high school for a
course or two but they have the
opportunity to participate in any of our
early college courses on the college
campus or our e-star courses and
honestly a good portion of our early
college courses where students come to
take the courses on campus as well as
these start our home school students
thank you chairman you're welcome thank
you are there any schools
community college system level schools
that are are beyond the community is the
university system or is our is
snoo getting involved with this process
at all
you know
i know at various points there have been
other colleges and universities that
have
um offered dual credit options i
they're not as comprehensive as what the
community colleges
as that partnership with new hampshire
high schools and i don't know if they're
still currently
doing that but
dual and concurrent enrollment as you
know has sort of taken off
nationally it's i think it's probably in
just about every state in one form or
another
the university of new hampshire
i had a couple courses that they were
offering for dual enrollment but um
really this is a
writ large this is a
program of the community college system
my question sharon is are they also
chasing the scholarship money are they
they they go in they get that 150
wherever you are 200
the scholarship program is only for dual
and concurrent enrollment courses taken
in partnership with the community
college
good okay
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair and thanks
very much beth and shannon for joining
us this afternoon um sort of a a
technical question based on what senator
waters was was saying and and he was
saying how the
the the
language change down on lines 12 through
very very specific to i think include um
as you say shannon schools like bishop
brady and trinity but i'm just wondering
how do those changes made in section two
translate into
students
from let's say bishop brady
uh being able to um to participate in
dual and concurrent enrollment programs
as laid out in section one
um in that instance they already do
there are already those courses offered
there but they don't have access to this
the funding
for that so so that's what i'm talking
about so so let's just
follow up mr chair so in looking at
section two
let's just say um bishop brady the
governing body bishop brady develops a
policy
so now the student at bishop brady in
grades 10 11 12 can participate in dual
or concurrent enrollment programs now
let's go up to section one
um
uh and i'm just reading from lines three
and four which is established at 150 per
course
to the ccsnh institution where a high
school or a cte student enrolls in a
concurrent enrollment class
um
high school is defined in the statute as
being a um
just pull it up here
194 23 the term high school shall mean a
public school or public academy
comprising and it gets into grade spans
so i'm just wondering
how
how this
i mean i it's clear the intent i agree
on the intent i'm just stuck on the um
on on how it passes through the various
sort of filters
in uh in section one where you've got to
be
you've got to be attending a high school
or cte um i would say that's a very good
question and one that we should take up
with
potentially with legislative drafting
yeah
okay thanks that had not come up before
as a question and and
and
in all fairness i don't know if the
definition definition of high school in
194 23 applies to this section or not
but it doesn't say that it's limited to
the section
that it's in there's a number of
references throughout statute we've gone
on there we've got this all over the
place yeah
my question though is that i asked
senator waters this
you have a student at holderness school
or kimball union
which is a non-public school that does
not reside in this state
but the way that's written i'm not so
sure now that they couldn't say hey we
want to get that 150 bucks for this kid
to participate in this concurrent
enrollment program
you're absolutely right however at this
point they don't offer any of those
courses but they could yeah but we would
support i think uh senator waters
mentioned a new hampshire resident i
mean that i think would make a lot of
sense
thank you
shannon you
okay
any other questions of the community
college system yes representative
cornell thank you i just want to say
thank you i think it's a great program
and i'm sorry i missed you this morning
beth but my chair called a meeting at
the same time as our advisory cte
committee this morning so i missed it
that's it good
okay are there any further questions of
the community college system not seeing
any thank you very much thank you all
thank you are there any other folks who
want to testify on this bill
then we'll close 421
and let's return quickly to 4 20 so we
won't have to come back to it you know
after lunch
um
caitlyn you had signed up
as a
ta if needed
correct
so i'm here if needed
okay let's go back to 420.
um just real quick does the committee
have the fiscal note attached
no okay so the one that was on the table
i noticed for some reason didn't have
the fiscal note the department did
provide the fiscal note the senate in
december
so i have copies of that to pass around
oh all righty okay
represent porter
well let's make sure everybody's sitting
down here i'm ready to go
okay you ready
okay go ahead
thank you mr chair so if i read the bill
right or understood what um mr bossy
said previous this is a this is an
ongoing grant correct and it so it will
be included in the budget
and off in future budgets correct
and the money will come from the
education trust fund the education trust
fund correct
what if there's not enough money
i'm fed if the education trust fund
doesn't have enough revenue to pay for
all the expenditures and subsidized by
the general fund there has been many
times in the past there has not been
enough funding in the education trust
fund in the past and the education the
general fund has subsidized it in the
last several years the education trust
fund the revenues have done very well
and therefore as a result we have not
needed a transfer but the assumption of
that transfer would um cover this
can i have further yes yeah i don't mean
to be what they call a debbie downer but
we have been through times where the i'm
sorry
i'll be a margie diamond then and then
um there have been times in the recent
past where the revenues of this i mean
right now we're doing very well but
there have been times when revenues are
very low and it's caused the budget to
eliminate other sources of revenue to
towns and cities and school districts
that they had been giving prior
but that's not going to happen with this
this is permanent until the day i die
not nothing is permanent um actually the
people that have the ability to make
something not permanent in this room um
as a as of right now the way this is
written it would be an ongoing um grant
that would uh continue on um
if there was not enough revenue to cover
the adequate education so one thing is
is this is putting it into the adequate
education grants which is a part of the
formula the first part is the statutory
piece that we are constitutionally
required to provide and then there are
several other grants that are in that is
in the adequate education funding
formula um the fiscal capacity grants
this extraordinary greed need grant the
and the stabilization grant those are
the other three pieces of that um
that entire amount equals adequate
education grant and then um we are
statutorily required to pay for that
entire amount regardless of the revenue
and regardless of the appropriation so
if there's not enough appropriation to
pay for it we also are able to draw a
warrant and pay that require that
obligation
okay so um
the state also promised um
large portions of the uh rooms and meals
taxes to communities um like 40
originally was the
the thing that wasn't going to go away
and
we haven't been able to do that
in many many many years if ever
um because it was always ch it's changed
in the budget process
would this be changeable in the budget
process
i guess what i'm saying is you know if
we're going to say to towns and cities
you're going to get this forever and
they're they're thinking they're going
to get it forever and they may plan
their budgets on getting it forever and
then suddenly it's not there anymore
that's going to be an increased burden
on property taxes or cause uh cause
uh schools to uh to have to do what they
have to do to cut their
their program so i'm i'm just trying to
find out is
this forever um
that question actually should be to your
colleagues in your in this room not
myself i do want to say in the 13 years
i've been at the department of education
so through seven biennium budgets the
adequate education funding formula and
the grants associated with that have
been changed in almost every single
biennium budget process and sometimes
outside that process so it would not be
atypical for a change to be made either
to increase or decrease amounts of
grants in the formula
yes margie finance can take it away
yes
absolutely
represent woodcock thank you chairman
um could you give me the layman's
explanation that's all i need uh of two
towns
on your chat
all right alexandria
and alton
so um the reason being that that
alexandria and alton wouldn't receive
any additional grants is because let's
see let me look at the calculation
um well i didn't care about them
particularly just like using that from
money to no money and no money right so
the um the formula requires you to have
a six million dollars of equalized
valuation for per
free and reduced lunch student in the
town okay so i'm going to look up
of course my computer has now locked
itself
so alton for example has a 16 million
dollar equalized valuation per free and
reduced lunch resident in the town um so
they would not be eligible for a grant
in either year um either year okay and i
just want to i do want to point out that
either year um
very much an estimate uh 23 is an
estimate 24 is even more of an estimate
because that's okay i'm just trying to
figure out and um so alexandria
is estimated to have an equalized
valuation of 5.9 million dollars or yeah
5.9 million dollars in fiscal year 23
per student
and in 24
and in 24 alexandria is estimated to
have an 18 or an 8.1 million dollars
therefore would not be eligible to
receive the grant because it's over six
million dollars per student now i do
want to point out two things because you
see obviously a substantially lower
amount in 22 um than you would receive
i'm sorry in 23 than you do in 24. and
the reason being here is because 23
there is a free and reduced lunch hold
harmless in the formula and in 24 as of
right now that has not been amended in
the budget
so as we
maybe just to draw people's memories
because it's been a little bit since
we've had an adequacy hearing in this
room
the department of agriculture had
waivers for free and reduced lunch
meals and then as a result school
districts have had challenges receiving
the applications back
as such
um in fiscal year 2022 of the budget
in house bill 2 it
allowed us to use the previous years
sorry two previous years like prior to
the pandemics free and reduced lunch
numbers um so that hold harmless
was in for 22 and 23 there's a similar
hold harmless which had us look at the
pre-pandemic ratio of free and reduced
lunch kids in a school district and use
that ratio um to apply to the current
enrollment so if you had 25 free and
reduced lunch kids before the pandemic
and then during the pandemic you only
have 18 percent we actually use that 25
percent and 23. so you're seeing that
number coming through in the 23 number
which is is
driving a higher grant amount in 24 for
the estimate we use the actual free and
reduced lunch numbers because as of
right now that 23 hold harmless expires
in the um in hb2
okay
i know that was not a super election
yeah thank you i appreciate the the
detail on my uh layman's term i hate the
hell of a detailed detail but no thank
you appreciate it
represent cornell
thank you thank you for taking my
question instead of using the whole
harmless free and reduced lunch did you
think of using the medicaid number like
we changed
so um i believe there is a bill that's
working its way through the legislature
i think the hearing is tomorrow morning
to potentially do that that likely will
go into effect i believe it's in fiscal
year 24. that does require us right now
um that bill is actually only requiring
us to
to submit an application to the us
department of education we then have to
be selected so i'm not sure if we're
going to be selected for that but we
will be working through that process
if that happens you'd use that number
for this too so if that happens those
kids that are medicaid eligible right
now become automatically eligible for
free and reduced lunch so it would have
a higher free and reduced lunch a number
in this formula including those medicaid
kids right now the free and reduced
lunch number only includes kids whose
parents have either filled out the
application or participating in snap wic
tnf orf or a foster care child
representative tanner
thank you how does this um apply to
charter schools
it does not apply to charter schools
okay thank you
further questions represent luno
thank you mr chair actually could i make
just sort of a comment
yeah i know this isn't um uh you know
deliberation here
what we have here we have an early bill
yeah yeah we're gonna have to maximize
on uh all our time on this bill
this right here
is information which has amendments for
this bill which i was going to speak to
after all this and and and that's good
and and and i think and i think my
comments sort of i haven't seen these
amendments but but but i think my
comments sort of go along the lines of
this i'm looking particularly at
manchester um
because it clearly gets uh gets almost
nearly four million dollars in the first
year of this which is which is not an
insignificant amount of money um and uh
and and for the for the manchester
school district i think every uh every
penny counts but to put that in context
when you're um when you've got about
four million dollars and and you're
educating approximately thirteen
thousand
students this comes out to about three
hundred dollars per student um in
increased state grant support and i want
to put that i want to sort of juxtapose
that with what the with what the school
funding commission uh found
uh last year which is um manchester
spends about the lease or budgets about
the least amount
per student for uh for public education
just about just a little over 12 um
six thousand dollars so twelve hundred
dollars i'm sorry twelve thousand
dollars per student the um uh state
average is certainly a lot higher than
that and for manchester at least based
on our our um our expert analysis
um in order for manchester's average
student to perform at state average
would uh would would cost um
closer to twenty one thousand dollars
per student so up from twelve thousand
to twenty one thousand dollars three
hundred dollars gets us puts us in the
right direction but it doesn't it
doesn't really move the needle
and um and i hope that we'll be able i
hope that this committee will be able to
uh to recommend amendments that do start
to move the needle um maybe not as far
as as a
as a
redesigned funding
plan and we do have an interim study
to look at that but um but i think given
the um
given what we've certainly heard on this
bill and on other bills the with uh with
state revenues where they are that that
we do something to move the needle for
our school districts but in particular
districts like like manchester and
newport
thank you
are there further
questions yes representative very
quickly thank you this money that comes
in is not limited to um it can be used
for any anything within the district is
that right correct
further questions
thank you caitlin
i'm just debating whether i should go
find uh do a pink car to hand all this
stuff out
um
but i do have some
concerns this bill was given to us it
came to our committee
on
not this past friday but the friday past
that just you know so we've had it about
a week
it came in and we recognized it was an
early bill
and we had about three days to get it
scheduled so we could have a hearing and
execute and get it out by the 14th
really basically by the 13th
which is wednesday
and so in looking at it it has a lot of
financial repercussions
and and possibilities in terms of our
working on and i have some materials
here and i think what i'll do is i'll
fill a pink card out so i can present
this stuff and discuss it because we're
just running out of time here
unfortunately so let me fill out one of
these pink cards here or or at least do
it
mr chairman
mr chairman lad
i'm not trying to be troublesome at all
but i
i if this is the policy commission the
committee and the finances the finance
committee is this relevant to our
committee and and i don't know the
answer to that that's a that's an honest
question
so um
for the record my name is rick ladd i
am a representative from haverhill new
hampshire here and i'm here to speak on
420.
420 is a bill which deals with the
trying to move the needle here in terms
of our supporting school districts
and i have some information which i'd
like to provide
regarding how we're doing that in the
same section of law so i'm going to pass
these materials out and i'm passing them
out for the simple reason that you might
want to look at them and they can be
considered when we exec on wednesday but
rather than making them available on the
web we can discuss them now if you so
desire so what i'll do is i'll hand out
these amendments and the support of
materials so you'll have them available
and maybe if representative ford you
might help me or somebody in
distributing the materials
that goes to everybody
also members the public should be
afforded the same
army
that can go out to everybody
this can go
that can go
okay
here's another amendment
oliver
another one
nose
uh
okay
i'm trying i think i'm missing one
myself
you should have three different
amendments
and there's one other which i don't have
that's 84 1384 no
81.
okay those are experts that they can be
handed out
and all the materials which are handed
out could also go to those that are
sitting behind me
does anybody have copies of 1381
[Music]
i might have it up there
okay i like to go ahead if
yeah that's what i was going to do right
now
okay
everybody should have
this sheet right here which is from the
education commission on the states
it's regarding special education
so you should have that form
you should also have a form that looks
sort of like this
which is dealing assess at the top a
proposed funding adjustment for special
education differentiated aid
okay
you should also have a sheet that has a
table on it with some
figures on it regarding most of your
towns
just one side
you should also have a sheet that looks
like this which shows
the number of handicapping conditions
that are reported by each district to
the state
department of education
okay you should also have three
amendments
13 81 and 1380
going downhill
okay
those are the
there was another sheet just says other
handy hammy candy cap i don't think you
have that you should you don't need that
that's not part of it
okay what i've done is i've looked at
the education funding bill which we had
presented to us by senator hennessey's
office
and and and the sponsors of that bill
we've seen that bill before or that
concept before many many a time
dealing with the ratcheting down from
the
the six
million dollar mark down to the lower
property valuations in terms of funding
students we have seen this before
um
as a as uh came out they originally came
out of the task force back in
in uh
that karen umberger had back in 2018 i
believe it was
i'm concerned that we're we're looking
at grants today out in the public
schools one of the areas that i'm very
very concerned about have been concerned
about for years
is the funding of differentiated
differentiated aid for special
education and how that impacts
policy-wise in the districts
we have one way of doing it right now
actually we have a hybrid if you were
looking at the sheet that i gave you
from the education commission in the
states
that sheet shows you how various states
fund special education there's there's
some different models in there
some give varying level of weighted
funding for various categories of
special education
we have 13 categories that are reported
you'll see that on the sheet right here
i just grabbed one of my i could have
grabbed 2020 i'd grab 2019 and made a
copy of that they all report the same 13
type categories
and it shows the number of students that
are in these categories throughout the
state the numbers and our number comes
up total special education handicapping
areas ieps a little over 30 000 kids in
it's very similar
for 2020 and if you went back 10 12
years it was right around 29 000 and
we're in the same ballpark we haven't
diverged a whole lot from that even
though our demographic has gone down in
terms of our students a total student
population we've seen that
special ed service area pretty much as a
constant
with the 30 000 mark
so that shows you the various categories
right there starting with autism and
then going down the visual impairments
my experience as a school principal
and uh administrator have been that
there are a number of handicapping
conditions out there in our schools
which take a lot more support a lot more
time
and a lot more funding to support than
others
and we all know that there's some
students that might receive special
education iep support in the area speech
pathology speech services therapy which
may only amount to a half hour a week
but we also know that there are some
other students which require a whole lot
more development in terms of speech that
could be a lot longer than that but the
majority are not as long as a student
that might have autism or a student that
might be tbi or a student that might
have orthopedic handicap which is more
costly and requires a lot more time
often than the student that's receiving
speech services
uh in the lower elementary grades
especially in trying to start developing
their articulation the way that we'd
like to see the child be at
so the costs different they're different
and from one handicapping area to
another you can see that in some of the
the sheets that come from various states
on the education commission estates they
may have at least six or seven different
categories in some cases we have a
hybrid in this state we have one one
funding amount for differentiated aid in
special education that's 2 000 plus
dollars uh there's a sheet which i have
that i made for you that shows that it's
this sheet right here
and you can see that you know our base
cost is identified
but
the special ed cost for
students is two thousand thirty seven
dollars eleven seven cents that's
projected for fy23
that's our estimated cost for fy23
that's the amount which we'll be using
in the funding is every student that has
an iep will receive that type of dollar
we also have a hybrid model in the state
where we do fund uh those students which
have a handicapping condition which
requires more than three and a half
times the base cost up to 80 percent to
the to 10 times and then it's funded
fully
that's a hybrid model so we have two
ways of funding special education in
this state
whereas many other states have prior to
getting that hybrid model that the
heavy weighted amount for the student is
in the cat aid category
there's other differing weights provided
i'm trying to look at and trying to
break that out somehow and it's very
difficult in the state seeing that the
material even though it's provided by
the individual school districts on this
district-wide basis in reported doe and
you can see that on the forms which i
provided you on the areas of one through
three in category a you'll see
developmental delay specific learning
disability speech or language
impairments
that's an area which generally speaking
does not cost as much as those 10 areas
down below
so what i'm proposing is that we address
the three areas in category 8
funding the way they're being funded
currently in differentiated aid
however recognizing that the costs
associated with the groups
areas in category b
will cost more and do cost more
so in category b
or category a
if you look at our total amount we do
for base adequacy
the amount of money we provide out of
base adequacy for the differentiated aid
right now is about 54 percent of the
base cost or
2037.11 cents
i'm proposing for the areas in
category b autism down through traumatic
brain injury and
visual impairments
the cost would be
of the base or 3 367
8 cents
that's approximately
500 more than what we're doing right now
in translating that to what the total
costs we would be adding into our budget
it comes out to exactly the same amount
of money that the
educational
extraordinary needs grant would require
14.7
14 point something million dollars
this increases that our budget by
another 14 point something million
dollars
if we follow through and do it with the
two categories a and b
if we didn't have that if don't have
that information and in my communication
with the department it can be gotten
then we could fund at a different level
and raise the amount of money which
we're funding for differentiated aid by
funding at a like a 0.67
of the base
if in funding at 0.67 you can see how
that would stack up in regard to what
your districts are getting right now
for example um
litchfield
which has
227.08 students qualifying for special
education
the current funding formula provides 462
000 some odd dollars
to that district
this funding formula would provide 576
thousand dollars
and you can go down and wade through and
see how it affects the various districts
in this room
so what i'm proposing this is one
amendment that you will see as i'm
trying to increase the funding for
differentiated aid special education
based upon
two categories it actually only
increases those
ieps or those handicapping conditions in
category b everything else just remains
the same it is in in those other three
iep areas in category a
the second thing i i'm adding in as an
amendment is that
when we have grant monies see the
differentiated aid right here is a part
of the constitutional requirement your
base cost and your differentiated aid
are constitutionally required every
student gets the same amount of money
regardless of the wealth of the
community or the poverty of the
community when we start talking grant
money
and stabilization you start going
outside that constitutional requirement
and you get into the fact that now a
district that maybe doesn't have the
high property values is entitled to some
fiscal capacity disparity aid or you're
entitled to a extraordinary grant need
program need grant program
that can change that can change however
the differentiated aid
goes up it doesn't get wiped out it's
part of the formula for the
constitutional requirement which we have
a conval case right in front of us right
now which we should all be aware of
and we need to be looking at
when i was on the funding commission for
the last year and a half that was
roughly about a year and a half ago dave
i can remember we discussed this and i
had concerns i said i like the idea of
funding special education and using
weights i'm not necessarily supportive
though of funding especially at one
increased total weight and i understand
it there's a lot more to the whole
funding formula at a level of 4.29 times
that that six thousand five hundred and
one dollars
i am supported though and rec and do
recognize that our policy right now as
we have it does not recognize in the
funding that follows our policy
that we're not properly funding all
special ed the way we should in our
state
and i'd like to propose that we look at
that in terms of that first amendment
the second amendment though i have and i
was just about ready to speak to
deals with accountability for the grant
you can write in accountability to
districts for grant money if you're
going to receive these grants there's
some accountability you have to ensure
that your your program that you're going
to use to try and see this achievement
and growth is approved by the department
of education and you can be required
also to
submit annual reports
to so showing that you are demonstrating
some growth or some gain for the areas
that you're
identifying or receiving that grant
money in
none of that grant money none of the
money provide can actually has to be
targeted that's the the point targeted
towards a specific area within our
funding formula
my intent in the second amendment is
that there be some accountability for
the education needs grant program you
can see that in that
amendment that amending language is an
exact extrapolation from the report that
came out in
2018 from the umberger study
the last amendment is an amendment which
would combine both the two first two
amendments into one if in case
this were to move forward
i'm presenting it primarily because i
want to open up the policy discussion
regarding
where special education is going
special education as alluded to at the
very beginning of the meeting we have
roughly meeting we had about 30 000 kids
in that program right now
our demographics going down our special
education is basically not
and the costs are increasing all the
time
and yet we know we have to provide these
stellar children the services they
deserve when i talked to superintendent
of schools in my district i asked the
other day about roughly five days ago
where are we going with special
education services she responded to me
that
the other health impaired category
is going off the charts in sau 23
a lot of its result of the pandemic
and kids not having the opportunity to
be eyeballed eyeball with their teacher
and
developing a number of health
impairments associated what they have
gone through they've been traumatized
so
in conclusion i offer these materials
for you to
consider to think about and when we come
back on wednesday
we can address it further in that formal
process thank you
representative luno
thanks very much um uh representative
cordelli mr chair and thank you rick for
um bringing um bringing these these
forward and i think we'll probably have
a a very robust discussion on these um
on wednesday for sure and i think this
is certainly an area that deserves um
robust discussion
one of the things that that that i liked
ab about senate bill 420 as it was
brought to us
is um
you know
you know it's it's you know something
it's at least something and and um but
it does it in a way that i that i it
applies that 14 million dollars
using two
essentially two factors access to
resources and and the end and poverty
and so so it does it through that
somewhat complex formula of of equalized
valuation divided by the number of
students that are that are uh enrolled
in free and reduced uh price lunch
program
so so it i i think it's a very
interesting way approach and and it and
it addresses through you know that 14
million dollars
um using those two very important um you
know factors
uh i've only really had a chance um uh
to look at uh your amendment 1380 as i
think you spoke to sort of that
um in in greater detail and um
and
what um
my my
i guess only criticism on 1380 is that
it um
it it it fails to what while it
certainly looks at it doesn't look at
at poverty so much as it looks at
costs associated with special education
but it fails to consider
uh the access to resources and you can
see that's borne out in your um in the
spreadsheet that you did with the with
the towns that i think several of us
you know represent and i want to pick on
manchester again because i like picking
on manchester uh because it's clearly a
a standout in the state in a number of
different ways but um
but what uh what six what
what
um what 420 as as
introduced to us
um does for manchester is increases the
state grant to manchester
by four almost four million dollars in
the first year
what
amendment 1380 does for manchester
is increases manchester's grant in the
first year by only 1.3 million dollars
not by four million dollars um and
that's
you know that's shown that's the
difference between the the six point
three million dollars is calculated in
in the amendment minus the five million
dollars that it currently gets under the
under the
um
the special education portion of its of
its uh adequate education grant so it's
only a 1.3 million dollar increase
it um
uh and it's and and it's and that's
happening because
because access to resources is not being
uh being considered in um in amendment
1380 so that in fact every school
district that has even one special
education student is going to be getting
an increased grant from the state
whether they need whether they need it
or not newcastle is going to get an
increase
um
whether they need it or not
and
and and i think in in
in
here in new hampshire
um
uh where where we have
failed to provide
adequate funding
tends to be in the dec in the districts
that that don't have access towards to
the resources they need
and and and i i i have to you know
applaud you rick because
you know we're we're all trying to work
on on ways to improve
education funding um but um but 420 is
as senator hennessey has brought it
you know doesn't put a lot of money onto
it but it is directing it to where it's
needed most
and um and there's you've put a lot of
material uh here on this and you've
worked i mean this is a lot of work rick
um and we don't have a lot of time to
get uh to get through it um but uh but
i'm looking forward to get to working
through the other amendments that you've
brought forward as well
um
but i just hope members of of this
committee will uh will consider
you know
that 14 million dollars and this goes
right to mary beth's question it's a
policy question um it's not the total
amount of money but it's how it's being
used and uh and i hope members of this
committee will uh will will look to
directing it to where it's
where it's needed um uh most
as being a um as being a policy goal
thank you no question yeah i know
there's no question there and you know
it's it's more informational what i'm
trying to provide here
is that
um
it is policy to me in the fact that
we're recognizing under differentiated
aid
that special education services
are an area that every child deserves
support in every child
and if you go back to the claremont
decision i believe it's back in 1994
thereabouts the one of the first ones
which we had there if you look in law
it also
addresses this issue that we are
required to provide this type of support
for all students and followed up by the
londonderry decision a little later that
poverty and
wealth of the community should not
impact what we believe is a necessary
service
and the only way we're going to get a
service is so we can afford to provide
the service so in order to make sure
your policy is followed out and so i
can't divorce costing and policy from
each other they're both very related
and if we're going to be providing these
very costly services today we've spoken
about a lot of special ed areas and we
are talking about services which are off
the charts in terms of
of of school districts being able to
provide
this right here is this amendment that
i'm bringing forward
is not subtracting from what has been
done in terms of directing poverty money
to areas that have the poverty the 14
plus million dollars that
senator hennessey's brought forward it's
adding to it and saying yes we are all
going to add another 14 million so it
comes out roughly around 30 million
dollars
to our funding for education to support
the policies
that we
need to be conducting or administering
and following through on in special
education
and we have these 13 categorical areas
right here we know that they cost more
than what we're providing
the funding commission saw that in fact
the idea was to weight it at 4.29 i'm
waiting here at what point eight
something of the base
which is a significant amount that's
less
but it's it's working to provide that
support for all children now if you look
at the vote that came out of the senate
in 420
there was one vote which was
oppositional to it the reason why
there's nothing in it for my towns
the money that's going out in 420 is for
poverty areas right
the
the community the senator that spoke out
said and spoke out quite elegantly is
that
yes it's good but it doesn't provide
anything for my community
and i'm looking for their students in
every one of these communities and
everything whether you're from
tuftonboro or you're from haverhill two
very different or hopkinton very
different communities in terms of
assessed property values and being able
to provide the funds needed to support
their programs
i believe that every student deserves
that opportunity regard regardless as
the court case says
regardless of your wealth
or your poverty
and that's why i've also decided
perhaps we need to be looking at
differentiated aid
it's an area which we haven't touched
since i've been on the in the house
that's 14 years
it's time to really be analyzing yeah we
have a cola we increase it somewhat
but we haven't made a significant change
at all to it and yet we know that we're
not able to provide all these services
without taking money out of other areas
and of our operational budgets in the
districts that is occurring to support
special ed so that's why i bring it
forward so we can have an honest
discussion
look at it you know i can go anyway on
this this does you know however i think
it's time that as a education committee
we have this discussion as a whole
uh mr chair did you want to uh continue
uh with questions now or
let us chew on this until uh our session
on wednesday and well let's delve deeper
it's a lot past lunch i don't think we
should be taking a whole lot more time
today real quick
okay yeah uh thanks so do these do these
amendments build on each other
no
no well one does the final one
includes there's two amendments one has
grant accountability in it okay that's
the one that comes out of that previous
task force yep and then the other one
deals with the
special education additional aid it
speaks to it's a simple amendment which
adds in under differentiated aid two
brackets category a category b and it
sets the funding amount for category a
and category b
the
funding those iep conditions listed
there are the same conditions which are
used by the department and you're having
to respond to the department as a
district
how many kids are in each one of those
categorical areas
so there's nothing changed there from
what we're doing it's it's primarily a
change in terms of
how we're funding
as mary beth said how we're funding the
question at the beginning the and
costing out these these uh services for
uh special education so is it a
possibility that someone would would
would um support all three amendments
it's possible
but they're so yeah
it's possible yeah you could you know
the the the amendments the last
amendment would be just amending the
bill with you know everything that we're
talking about right so
so amendment 1384
combines
senate bill 1420
with
13 amendment 1380 and 81. that's correct
yep
it's like
the senator used to be that was here our
senate representative used to be on the
uh from where they had always a stack of
amendments sitting beside him when
they're in exact session and that one
didn't work so i'll go to this one this
one and finally work through their
amendments
another quick question or uh do you want
to hold that to wednesday
okay
technically the hearing is still open
for anybody that's here
thank you
i don't know how quick this will be
we are talking about uh thank you for
taking my question
we are talking about grant money
that is being provided by the state or
is this
federal grant money
that is coming into the state we're
talking about money that's appropriated
by the state of new hampshire okay
thank you
so uh
i guess
we will uh
end the hearing on
4 20 today and uh
have a little bit of uh review to do
for wednesday
and um should be an interesting
morning on wednesday
so thank you very much
all
you